cnn data reporter crunch the numbers and
it turns out republicans have not polled
this well before a midterm in 80 years
in all of these years where democrats
actually were defeated they were polling
up
so it's going to be particularly brutal
the good news is well there's no good
news but joe biden's trying to make it
seem like there's good news saying we're
in a robust recovery and that
everything's fine everybody but it's
weird that the messaging is everything's
fine when people are looking at gasoline
nearing five dollars a gallon the latest
a average for the country is four
dollars was it four dollars and 91 cents
in california mendocino i think is the
name of the city nine dollars and sixty
cents a gallon the highest highest in
the country and thirteen states have gas
already over five bucks people have been
telling us in illinois it's five bucks
so uh yeah i'm pretty sure it's the
economy stupid but of course we can also
talk about what's going on with these uh
drag queen kids shows because texas and
florida have two reps that are seeking
to make it a felony to make it illegal
to bring kids to these things
i'm pretty sure it already is
but okay and what's happening now is uh
unsurprisingly the left and democrats
are actually defending these shows for
kids so
i don't know how you defend that i don't
know what regular person's gonna think
that's okay but that's where we're
currently at we gotta talk about that we
gotta talk about steve bannon he's
subpoenaing nancy pelosi striking back
peter navarro was arrested we got all of
that crazy stuff to talk about cnn's
collapse of course and a bunch of other
news joining us to talk about all of
these things is bethany mendel hey would
you like to yeah introduce yourself yeah
uh so i am a homeschooling mom of five
and the editor of a series of children's
books called heroes of liberty which is
sort of
a take on children's literature that
doesn't have grad queens and
um there's no transgender characters
instead we're just sort of like looking
at uh characters from
like recent past and not so recent past
so alexander hamilton ronald reagan john
wayne and just sort of you know
telling our children about all of these
people and founding principles and ideas
in a way that
um is engaging and wonderful
illustrations and yeah and i'm also a
contributing writer for deseret news
they're pro-natalist writer
people we got to talk about these uh
what's going on with this libs of tick
tock stuff because apparently now these
these drag drag kid events are getting
cancelled yeah they're you know uh the
crazy thing is one of the latest tweets
from libs of tiktok is
there was a i guess uh some mayor
organizer said we weren't informed they
were planning on doing drag queen story
hour it wasn't included their initial
proposal they just put it in oh wow so
yeah we'll talk about that stuff yeah
yeah we got we got luke hey guys lots of
crazy political news i'm so excited to
be disappointed by the republicans when
they take office welcome back beautiful
and amazing human beings my name is
lukerdowski of we are change.org if you
want to support me you can on uh
thebestpoliticoshorts.com where you can
get the shirt that i'm wearing right now
it's good to be back thank you so much
for having me ian good to see you as
well dude luke i love you man it's great
to see you back
i i heard you were doing some crazy
stuff while you were out and about lots
of crazy things you guys talk about
florida is incredible
beautiful bilderberg in washington dc
all of it it's been just a wild last
couple hours you're a superstar man
thank you thank you for coming back
bethany great to see you i'm i'm in a
kind of a stop look and listen mode
right now i feel like there's a lot
happening this week and i want to hear
you guys this is crazy elon musk's deal
the financing is being i got too many
stories matthew mcconaughey holy cow
yeah his comments struck me deep yeah
as an actor the january 6th would get
meetings and hearings the abc news guy
oh my god i didn't see it so it wasn't
on fox and so it didn't happen there's
no way for a fox viewer to see it
that's right exactly i am also here in
the corner pushing buttons i'm very
excited to be here and hear from bethany
who has a lot of children i had five
siblings i was selling here before we
started so i'm stoked to hear what she's
got to say it's unique perspective
before we get started my friends head
over to surfinginternetsafe.com
and pick up virtual shield a virtual
private network service you will get 50
off a lifetime discount when you head
over to surfing internetsafe.com
virtualfield is a virtual private
network what this means is you get a
basic layer of security for yourself as
you're browsing internet so hackers
corporations governments have a lot
harder of a time trying to spy on you
and steal your data when you go to
surfing internet safe.com you can get
virtual shield when using their virtu
their vpn service your traffic is routed
through their secure and encrypted
servers that means any restrictions
censorship and blocks on your internet
are bypassed you can also get vpn plus
an additional suite of services that
expand your protection and offer an
enhanced level of service these features
include ad blocking malware blocking
unrestricted streaming protection plus
monthly maintenance and priority phone
support for all one low monthly price
enjoy browsing on a fast reliable and
secure always free network i'm sorry
always available it's 60 days risk free
not completely free available on all
major platforms windows mac ios and
android virtual shield does all the work
for you your entire connection becomes
secure private and encrypted and it
routes your internet through advanced
encrypted servers across the globe
virtual shield will also completely
encrypt your wi-fi connection blocking
hackers and everyone else from accessing
any of your data that is again 60 days
risk-free no it costs money but support
virtual shield they're our first sponsor
they've been with us from the very
beginning and we're proud to um shout
them out and we are grateful for their
support so again surfing
internetsafe.com but also head over to
timcast.com and become members to help
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to exclusive segments
of the from this show monday through
thursday at 11 p.m so we will have one
of those special segments up tonight you
will also be supporting our journalists
who write we just
we're hiring another journalist we just
hired adrian norman you saw him on the
show he was awesome hopefully we'll have
him out here joining us on the show once
again so don't forget to also smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show right now take that url
posted on every social media platform if
you really do want to help now let's
read the first story we got this from
breitbart
cnn's enton polling shows gop will take
huge house majority best position in
over 80 years this is fascinating he
said quote
i would say they're looking very good
from the historical context basically i
took the best republican positions on
the generic congressional ballot at this
point in the midterm cycle since 1938.
the generic ballot basically is would
you vote for the generic republican or
generic democrat in your district and
guess what since 1938 the republican
two-point lead on the generic
congressional ballot is the best
position for republicans at this point
in any midterm cycle in over 80 years
it beats 2010 when republicans were up a
point it beats 2014 2002 1998 where
democrats led by a point and in all of
those four prior examples that make this
list of the top five look at that who
won a majority it was the republicans
who won a majority he added now of
course the election is not being held
tomorrow and we'll see sometimes history
isn't always prologue but my estimate
for the 2023 house makeup if the
election were held today which again it
isn't we're still five months five
months from tomorrow would be
republicans 236 seats to 241 seats
democrats 194 to 199 that's based off of
a formula of seat to seat race ratings
from the cook political report and
inside elections now this is coming from
cnn
data reporter on jake tapper's show
perhaps hearing that's coming from cnn
it must be even worse the fascinating
thing is there was an article from the
washington post that was like democrats
are going to lose the midterms here's
why it's a good thing my favorite line
in their opening paragraph is every poll
can't be wrong they're basically saying
they're saying republicans clear right
they're like republicans are going to
win
and you know as much as people might not
want to believe it every poll can't be
wrong and i just laughed because i'm
like not only are all of the polls wrong
but they're actually wrong in favor of
republicans i'm sorry they're wrong in
favor of democrats meaning
if every poll right now is saying
republicans are going to win and it's
like the generic ballot is plus two gop
it's probably plus seven yeah or plus
ten
so this is going to be amazing uh luke
you were you were excited to be
disappointed yes absolutely i mean i i
think it's very fair to say that there
definitely is a political transformation
i i question a lot of the polls that are
out there but i think that this
political transformation that's
happening is a precursor to the economic
transfer uh transformation that we're
seeing under the biden administration
and under the the previous
administration that essentially is
creating one of the largest transfers of
wealth from the poorest people to the
richest people we saw this from the
beginning of covet we saw this with the
secret federal reserve bailouts we're
seeing the effects of this the effects
of this are being felt everywhere i
forgot which corporate media network was
interviewing a random person at the gas
pump just just couple hours ago the
video is going viral on twitter because
the person being interviewed is like
this is absolutely insane this is going
to uh motivate me to get politically
involved and i'm going to be voting for
the republicans and this was a person
who was previously a democrat before who
publicly is stating this so obviously
this larger political transformation has
a lot to do with our with our current
financial situation which is absolutely
ruined and and left a lot of people in
havoc i fully agree with that man i it
strikes me as like political football
the the pendulum is swinging both
directions cnn's happy because they're
either going to trash trump or trash
trump and uh
but it's an economic crisis and it's a
transformation economically either into
some world economic forum you'll own
nothing and be happy renters world or
something that we control into some sort
of maybe you know
democratically cryptography
cryptographic you know decentralized
something new that hasn't been created
who knew stealing people's ability to
have upward economic mobility wasn't
popular who knew giving corporate
bailouts was unpopular who knew raising
gas prices stopping domestic energy
production was unpopular obviously the
people are feeling it no lies no
propaganda could cut through the reality
of the horrible situation that we're all
facing and what are republicans going to
do yeah i mean that's the question
you're going to be disappointed as
always absolutely 100 people i mean but
it's so frustrating because
this is such a moment and i i don't feel
like republicans are really i mean
they're talking about sort of opening
domestic energy production and but i i
don't feel like anyone in power sort of
understands what is actually happening
with american families i am in a
facebook group for large families and
it's a really fascinating window into a
lot of different sort of ways of life
and the number of posts that people are
making like how can i stretch rice and
beans what different recipes can i do
how can i
be creative cooking for 10 people well
different types of vinegar
different types of vinegar and different
types of oils give you all these
different combinations ian we were
ordering supplies and ian was like just
buy a bunch of vinegar and we got like
20 white wine vinegar your red wine
vinegar your tarragon vinegar your malt
vinegar your balsamic vinegar your
coconut oil your avocado oil your olive
oil you see what they do in haiti mud
cake
you take mud and you put a little sugar
and salt and butter in it and then you
flatten it out and the mud is like not
food
but it fills your stomach so you know it
doesn't hurt anymore i mean we're not
there yet but the
they will regret making people care this
much it is
impacting every corner of people's lives
in a way that
this will drive anger i mean they're
talking about you know abortion will
fuel the midterm like none of that will
fuel the midterms it is people driving
to the gas tank and then not being able
to go grocery shopping
it's amazing to me that they're really
driving the gun control narrative right
now the media is pushing it like crazy
and i'm like i'm pretty sure the dude
who turns on the news
it's just all going past him every every
word they say with like gun control and
mass shootings and he's sitting there
just thinking
i don't have any money left yeah i'm not
going to be able to fill up they're
trying to change the conversation
they're trying to make it emotional
abortion guns but my point is you can't
because when there's somebody who just
is they're holding the receipt in their
hand for a 100 tank of gas and then
you're like listen to me gun control and
abortion and they're like what did you
say there was what was that i'm looking
at myself interesting statistic that was
like 80 percent of people are worried
right now financially 80 80
you you cannot just wish cast that away
with gun control or abortion or anything
at the end of the day it's going to be
the price of gas and and the ripple
effect of all of that well not only that
but but we're just coming from the from
the era of covid where small businesses
small operations were shut down by two
non-essential they weren't essential
yeah but two weeks of slowing the thread
walmart was allowed to be open
costco
and this and this was happening under
the trump administration again the biden
administration is continuing the same
kind of economic pain and suffering with
all of their policies all their
regulations all their taxes all the
moves that they're making that hinder
the average person from having any kind
of upward economic mobility to be fair
trump did nothing yes yeah and joe biden
is pushing regulations so it was the
governors and the dem in these
look at florida come on tell me
florida's doing bad well florida doesn't
floor's doing okay
but it was there right now it was mike
pence that that first said we need two
weeks to slow the spread he's the first
one that instituted that idea and
everyone's kind of went along with it
which is actually bonkers so so you know
again florida did well because they were
able to stand out and say no no no we're
not going to punish everyone there was
also other ecological events that
happened before covid that hit florida
very severely and and their businesses
were suffering before kovid and that was
another reason why desantis made a very
strong stance saying no we can't shut
down the small businesses of mom and
pops we can't have thug police officers
walking around intimidating grandma
telling her shut down her little trinket
shop we can't be doing that in the state
this is unethical the reaction the
causes of that of stopping the global
supply chains of stopping the world
economy we're feeling the reverberations
of that right so many other states that
were feeling that and they went whole
hog i mean california was doing that new
york was feeling that the states who
stood up and said absolutely not we're
all republican states people have eyes
and they can see that in florida in
south dakota things went back to normal
much quicker than they did in california
new york well florida led the way the
corporate media said that it was about
the census was good south dakota also
but but florida was the first public big
state that everyone was saying was going
to lead to the killing of thousands and
hundreds of the grim reaper
i i think you're wrong south dakota
never locked down i'm pretty sure
christine was like never gonna happen
and they never had a mass mandate and
florida did lock down for a little bit
didn't they yeah yeah for like two or
three months yeah right yep and then
they came out and said we're done with
this and they took and and she and
the
christie gnome right that's her name and
yeah she said we will absolutely not
have a mass mandate i trust people to
make the right decision for themselves
and their community but as far as the
narrative the major attacks were on on
florida the major attacks oh 100 yeah i
think i i you know they they did try
going after south dakota they were like
this is where the hot spots gonna be
they were claiming it was going crazy
and the population density is so low
there yeah but that's why they go after
florida because these are major urban
centers miami's massive yeah but miami
had different rules than the rest of
florida so like i was planning a
vacation i think it was december of 2021
thinking like we're gonna go to florida
and be free and then i started looking
at the children's museum in boca oh it's
still closed oh let's go to this oh it's
masks for two-year-olds and it like it
became sort of we just sat in our
backyard and swam because nothing in
florida where we were staying was
actually really open i i just remember
how crazy it was when the lockdown first
started and we had a small backyard that
was like what like a 0.2 of an acre or
something and we're just sitting in the
backyard like nobody can go anywhere
there's nothing open and then we were
like we got to get out of this place
yeah we bought a house in in uh just in
march of 2020. now imagine if you were
living in in new york city imagine if
you're living in a huge apartment where
you can't escape or you don't have a
backyard you have roommates they closed
the they closed the parks and they they
did
padlocks on the playground and it was
that uh israeli rabbi
yeah
he was on the show in brooklyn
yeah um okay uh sorry jewish uh you know
pastor came out there yeah yeah it came
out there and then you know cut it open
and made a stand and they arrested him
yeah he went to jail for for making a
stand just for allowing children to be
able to be outside and not cramped up in
little small apartment buildings which
was absolutely ridiculous and crazy and
insane to see that entire process play
out and very few people actually stand
up for their own personal liberty and
will but but what we're seeing from
those larger effects
happened
during the start of covet the larger
economic effects that we're feeling
right now is because of what happened
then yes so let's let's jump to this
next story this from cnet gas prices are
at record highs here's why they won't
drop anytime soon okay sure
13 states a gallon of regular is
averaging more than five bucks
in mendocino california
960 a gallon they say 13 states
california they say it's over five bucks
california is averaging 6.37 a gallon
right now the national average is
4.92 cents
this number
is apocalyptic in politics yeah people
that you i guarantee you you go to the
you go to a random place working class
place and you ask them anything about
pelosi the supreme court and they're
gonna say i don't know i don't know i
don't know i can't afford gas how am i
supposed to get to work and it's it's
june so we're only going up from here i
mean that's the thing like has gas ever
gone down in the summer and
right now the summer driving months are
when it goes nuts peak driving season
we're entering those yes we're entering
i i eight dollars an average they're
saying my kids are sick of i drive
you know back and forth whatever and i
just look at them like i have never seen
gas above
350. i mean is that that's right right
like never above 350.
the record was four or something
underwater i've never seen it though
because it's always in places like
california
i've never seen it
oh yeah what more what was the national
average during the bush years it would
be important it did hit as high as four
bucks but
i think it was four in chicago but
national average was probably been 350 i
don't remember it ever over 350. but now
i mean i drove i drive by something 520
today cnn's saying it's gonna be six
dollars and 20 cents per gallon by
august i think it's gonna be higher i
think it's gonna be higher i keep on
doing this thing i'm never a person who
lets my tank go past half
and i keep on sort of like pushing it
like well maybe a gas will go down
tomorrow maybe it'll go down tomorrow
and it just keeps on going up i i i
would not be surprised if we hit seven
or eight yeah yes buying gas has become
more like the stock market
yo
three 325 was the highest under george w
bush yeah see the item
on average and then 368 under obama
and then under trump the average was
280 highest at its highest lowest was
like a 1.50 yes i remember it was under
two and i was like judging when i was
filling up my tank i have a minivan and
it was costing like 35 to fill the
minivan now it's 87. to be fair under
bush in his first few years it was a
dollar forty on average yeah decently
and then it started skyrocketing towards
the end and then under obama so
it's funny because people keep pointing
out that they show these images of four
dollars a gallon gas under bush and
they're like i remember when gas was
this high why are you blaming biden no
and i'm like yo that those weren't the
average prices you're looking at
california and new york there's there's
that one gas station in dc on the hill
that's next to the heritage foundation
yeah and everyone always pick takes
pictures in front of that one it's like
well that's not actually the average but
i drove past i was driving my kid into
rockville maryland today and i passed 5
20.
wow that's here i was getting a haircut
and as i'm getting a haircut
people in this area they're like do you
see the gas prices do you see what they
are so even even local people are
talking about how there's uh one store
that's offering uh you know thirty
percent off a gallon if you buy a carton
of cigarettes okay we gotta we gotta go
to this store we gotta smoke it right at
the gas i mean these are conversations
that are happening with average people
with normal people that are getting
politically involved because they were
thrown into a mess which sadly you know
a lot of ignorance has led to this
because we saw the warning signs from a
very long time ago ever since 2008 the
signs were there but there was a warning
sign in joe biden talking about climate
change yeah so again i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna make a moral statement on
climate change but joe biden and
democrats have long said we need exactly
this
yeah they want high gas prices so people
don't drive so there's less carbon
emissions joe biden shut down keystone
he banned uh fracking on public lands he
shut down various oil and gas leases
josh hawley has the list better than me
he took action specifically over climate
and environmental issues and that is a
major contributor to why you are paying
so much of the gas problems
no no it's working i looked into getting
a hybrid i i was like we can't we can't
keep on doing this but the problem is
they keep on talking about like this is
the solution but it's not because the
cars aren't available and they're not i
i can't drive in a hybrid i have five
kids we need more space than that it's
not well so
the the end result of all of this look
if you if you follow after the
environmental narrative it is going to
be suffering yeah they that that's it
that's the only way in in france they
put a petrol tax resulted on on you know
a a tax on the fuel resulted in what 18
months of rioting
because it's it's simple when they come
out and say you've got to cut back
they're saying it's going to get really
it's going to get a lot worse for you
your standards will be
they're saying you are the carbon that
they want to get rid of and again we
were talking about this yesterday biden
is talking about these high gas prices
being a quote incredible transition he
was talking about how he wants to build
back better how he wants to set up more
green policies as we're literally
importing oil from saudi arabia that all
of that in the name of green policies
instead of domestic energy production
and then there's these then there's
these politicians like this democratic
senator came out what's bragging how the
gas prices don't matter to her because
she has an electric vehicle so
let's think about what happens in in in
november
gas prices are going to hit a peak in
august yeah a couple months beforehand i
don't think there's a single word a
democrat could say at that point that's
it yeah they're going to put out all the
ads in the world and i wouldn't be
surprised if they actually if we have
like a record i'm i don't mean this
literally but i'm saying i would not be
surprised if there's a record low spend
from democrats because they're like just
gonna write it off don't waste the money
yeah save it for 2024. you would think
that they would have their messaging a
little better right like they're talking
about gun control they're talking about
abortion and they're they're talking
about like well i don't care about guest
persons because i haven't this is a
great transition we're building back
better this is awesome this is great for
the environment robust recovery yeah
like if the jobs report is good
therefore all of your suffering doesn't
matter because someone got a job
inflation is transitory it's temporary
oh it's actually good for you yeah it's
crazy it's absolutely insane the talking
points that they're releasing i'd call
it gaslighting if it wasn't
so insane
it's like it's it's that's the
definition though but it's just crazy i
liken it to that family guy joke where
peter's in an elevator with one other
guy and he farts and then says it was
you
like that's what they're doing they're
saying
the economy is better than ever and
you're like bro i'm pumping my gas right
now right here yeah i'm standing here
so i think when they say the best
polling in 80 years
when you consider the fact that the
polling has been skewed by what like
seven points
nah it's going to be
i you know people are calling it a red
wave right there's going to be a gop red
wave and then some people start saying
wow look at the polls it's going to be a
tsunami i'm like no it's going to be a
great flood and the democrats better
start building that what what is the
senate numbers do you know what the
senate numbers are looking like um i
think it's going to be like a couple
seats it's like republicans might have
52 or 53 okay all right because then
that's that's who knows man look it's
we're five months out that's an eternity
and we got to speculate on what's going
to happen in august then speculate
what's going to happen in october but
i'll add this
we don't have any fertilizer because of
the war with between ukraine and russia
that severely limited our uh resources
there so
they predicted this months ago back in
february march the fall harvest is going
to be brutal it's going to be down 40
percent we're going to see food costs
skyrocket
there's going to be a shortage of diesel
meaning you're not going to have the
food and if it does come i got to tell
everybody right now if you don't have
emergency supplies or whatever it sounds
like you might be fighting over the last
can of beans with agnes in the parking
lot of walmart maybe that's a little too
much though but i'll tell you this
you're certainly going to be fighting
over toilet paper because that already
happened yeah yeah
it's not crazy because we all just went
through it or baby formula i know i you
know it part of me is like oh man to say
you're going to be fighting over beans
sounds crazy
people are already there's videos of
people fighting over baby formula yeah
because it's life and death that's the
problem with baby formula as opposed to
almost any other product on the market
it is not replaceable you can't just
give a baby who's like three months old
whole milk and be like good luck to you
and you can but what about nesquik if
you mix it in that's good right probably
not no wouldn't do it
what about the
gmo lab mate bill gates milk that he's
developing and making on very uh
coincidentally as well you can test it
on goats coincidentally look if you're
an investor and you see the news who
would not be investing in future
materials metamaterials whatever you can
do like fake meat graphene for instance
i got
graphene graphene yeah yeah what is that
it's a hexagonal lattice monoatomic
carbon it's like a layer of carbon a
flat layer of atomic carbon and it's um
hexagonal so it's like looks like a
honeycomb okay it meant here it's
actually some right here it's a powder
black powder it's pure carbon did i just
open a pandora as well yes
let's let's let's plays like the 21st
century steel it's an incredible
building material with electric sorry
i'll get into it later it's drink
they're they're they're they use it for
making better batteries it's a very
powerful one touch screen wall
it's going to be revolutionary my my
point here is when you're watching the
collapse in this way you're going to be
investing in food farmland um chicken
raw materials chickens bill gates is
buying farmland he's making fake meat
and he's making fake breast milk how
convenient that that aligns perfectly
with his agenda i mean he's a
businessman he wants to invest in what
he needs to invest in it makes sense
doesn't it good he's definitely uh
cornered the market to say the least i
could say a lot more about this but but
from everything that i'm seeing i think
in the future there's going to be a lot
more economic instability i think that's
uh that's without a doubt definitely
happening here in the united states i
think we're going to be seeing more
limited uh
you know supplies uh you know random
items that are not going to be available
i don't think it's going to be as bad as
it will be in places like in africa and
the middle east which are definitely
expected to deal with the full brunt of
this larger geopolitical proxy war
that's happening inside of ukraine
especially with the wheat and the
fertilizer crisis which will hit them
the richer countries will be able to
afford a lot of the wheat a lot of the
food they will be importing at other
countries that are poor in the middle
east and africa they're going to be
facing some significant problems that
is going to be overwhelming so um i
don't know how bad it'll get for us in
the united states
but let's take a look at what our
leaders are telling us in the story from
daily mail democratic senator debbie
stabenow brags that it doesn't matter to
her how high gas prices are because she
drives by every station in her electric
vehicle let them eat cake let them drive
tesla okay so if the meme of the person
drowning getting a high five from the
person on the boat were a person i was
like holy cow i cannot imagine a better
emp
that's insane remember when cole bear
said the same thing yeah he's like i
don't care if it's 20 bucks again i
drive an election i said the same thing
so so i was uh i was on facebook and i
see these memes because i have like
thousands of people following me and
someone posted uh gas prices are not joe
biden's fault or like you know something
like that and then i responded with
you know being snarky
if you can't afford an electric car you
can't afford to drive
you we are and i was like we are all in
this together with the environment and
and you drive around with carbon
emissions everywhere carrying nothing
for this world and then the lady who
posted it she was like i can't afford an
electric car and i said oh it's only
fifty thousand dollars
and she's like i can't afford i mean
then then what do you think is going to
happen when you drive up gas prices or
celebrate it yeah i mean this was the
lesson of covid was the have the war
between the haves and the have-nots you
were essential and you could go to work
or you were not essential and you
couldn't go to work i mean this was in
in every way what they chose to shut
down and what they chose to keep going
um the best part is that plum like
plumbers and labor and stuff was like
some of it was essential but all of the
journalists were essential it was like
okay that's okay everyone else go home
but if you're a blue check washington
post reporter you're good yeah you think
that uh you guys ever follow salt water
as a fuel you looked into that at all no
some people are burning salt there's got
john kansas we pulled this up in the
after show maybe he was uh running
microwaves through salt water looking
for a cure for cancer one frequency lit
it on fire salt water just a just a
frequency and then you know i haven't
heard a lot about it for 12 years but
maybe because it's nonsense there's a
video on youtube of him doing it and the
other scientists are like we should talk
about it on the after show but i mean
there's a video point there's a video on
youtube about how the earth is
flattening come on i'm not saying the
earth's not flat you're saying it's not
well well i'm saying
if it's true that saltwater has a lot of
i mean a lot of potential energy in it
if we really could burn the stuff why is
it like a cabal that's intentionally is
this just like a wealth transfer they're
going to charge as much as they can for
oil well until people can't pay any more
let's entertain
the the idea that you can burn salt
water i don't know if that's true or not
i'm not i'm not you know just buy
someone in the chat like this might not
be the right word but um like you know
release heat from release yeah the issue
is that you know i did some uh reporting
on the desalination plants in california
it's actually really bad we cannot just
pull water from the ocean it creates
brine which then sinks to the bottom and
causes serious problems so the idea that
we can extract from the oceans is not a
long-term solution to anything so even
if we could take salt water and use it
for some kind of fuel you're going to
have byproducts you're going to have
waste products so that doesn't seem like
a solution jeez i mean
oil is giving us enough of a product
byproduct problem as we go well look at
batteries you know these electric cars
you know they're not made out of some
fairy winged al gore coming up and
pooping them out of his you know
another reasons
[Laughter]
these electric batteries don't come out
of nowhere they're not you know they're
not magic they don't just
they don't aren't just made out of
environmentally friendly you can't get
them exactly and there's a limit in
getting them and there's a shortage in
getting them and when you do get them it
is extremely destructive to the
environment there's a huge entire long
process and a lot of of even the solar
panel stuff a lot of it is just bigger
scams and when you look at the the
carbon footprint of of getting
uh you know they say you get it from
sand no you know the way of getting it
is it's it's so complicated it has such
an effect on on the environment it
really makes you question this entire
larger scheme as it's like as a ponzi
scheme it's all about language yeah
recycling also another scam that a lot
of people don't like to talk about a lot
of the recycled material literally was
shipped over to china china just dumped
it into the ocean and now we have whole
islands filled with plastic so
there are legitimate issues that we
could talk about when it comes to the
destruction of our environment we don't
talk about that there's elaborative
ponzi schemes that literally transfer
the wealth from poor people to rich
people all in the name of fighting the
environment literally giving the money
to the people destroying the environment
which is which is bonkers i was in
chicago like this is like 15 years ago
and they had this these big city
garbage bins and there's one hole that
says recycle and one hole it says
garbage and it goes to the same place
and they both go to the same shoot
that was like i looked at it i'm like
wait a minute it just goes on a slide
into one garbage can but i still i know
this intellectually and yet i still
cannot not do it it's like been
ingrained from childhood where you have
to separate the cardboard and the
plastic and the garbage and i can't not
if it's got food material on it you
can't recycle it anyway i know it's all
nonsense and yet i have this like ocd
that i cannot not do it i was in i was
flying through through uh i think i was
in dallas
and i ordered an arnold palmer or
something lady comes and she brings it
to me and i'm in texas and she gives me
a paper straw and then i laughed and i
was like paper straws huh and then she
goes some dumb little girl complains
about
plastic and also we can't have straws
anymore and then i started laughing i
was like you get it yeah you know
exactly what's up shout out to boyan
slat in the ocean cleanup project have
you guys been following his work i
interviewed him uh when he went to
bilderberg he actually gave me an
interesting comment about his take there
but he's also a fascinating extremely
young person that uh has been doing some
really fascinating work when it comes to
cleaning up the mess from essentially
the chinese uh dumping all the trash
into india into the ocean and river when
all the developing countries the the
pacific gyre that giant texas-sized
swirling patch of plastic trashies out
there with these giant ropes cleaning it
up but where does it go when he cleans
he brings it back to shore and then they
got to figure out what to do with the
plastic you can break it back down into
oil if you heat it up with low oxygen or
no oxygen environment you can reconvert
it there's a there's bacteria that
started eating it yeah there's bacteria
there's also mushrooms pestilopsis
microspores is a fungus that can consume
it turned into sugar
you gotta put sugar yeah you grind it up
with the little plastic pellets and then
you run it through an aqueous solution
and spray it with the fungus with the
spores and then over like a week it
breaks it down into sugar that's cool
let me read a little bit from this
article this is funny the average cost
of an electric vehicle is fifty six
thousand four hundred and thirty seven
dollars which is approximately a hundred
ten thousand dollars higher than the
industry average
so these i'm just i'm really hoping that
whatever ends up happening in november
we never forget they'll let them drive
tesla's line and it becomes like a thing
like let them drive teslas you know
these people are just like they're
complaining about gas prices why don't
they just drive teslas yeah buddha judge
said it he's like people should buy
electric cars they're like oh little
things there's not enough of them
there's no batteries there's no cars
that's why the demand of them is going
up yeah i i just placed an order for a
ford transit that will arrive maybe at
the end of the year we're hoping tesla's
back ordered incredibly long prediction
um i think joe biden will likely invoke
the defense production act and some kind
of the democrats will introduce some
kind of bill magic massively fund
electric vehicle production in this
country and
not like cars uh
big rigs that would help you on muscle i
thought you said china wrong tim uh you
said china because biden's probably
going to be giving all the business to
china probably more than anywhere else
that's where he's buying the solar
panels that he's importing i'm saying
when the diesel shortages hit in august
you think gas prices are a problem
you look if the truckers are going to be
spending 10 bucks a gallon on diesel
yeah a lot of them are going to be like
i'm not driving anymore yeah then your
products are going to skyrocket so i
think joe biden's going to step in and
be like we got a problem with prices and
shortages man come on we gotta have to
do the defense production
it's gonna be like fruits and vegetables
that are gonna fly off the shelves and
that will be completely scarce
yeah it took him a really long time to
actually admit that there was a baby for
strong formula shortage and he didn't
really do anything about it i wonder if
he's actually going to do anything about
that all you guys think you're going to
have strawberries come october
people people no more strawberry ice
cream no
the things that need to be shipped and
shipped quickly not going to happen yeah
that's right yeah so
you know whenever i go to the store you
don't really bugs me the strawberries
you got to like check them you got to
open it up and make sure there's no mold
in there and then sometimes you do after
a couple days they're all moldy yeah and
that that's because they have to be
transported very quickly but if you buy
the strawberries that last more than
three days they're tasteless they're
gross yeah so there's no middle ground
or frozen strawberries really strong
feelings about strawberries
avocados done so
12.92 cents at costco for a six-pack
whoa
two bucks an avocado yeah that's the
millennial apocalypse
avocado toast i know i just saw it on
instacart and i was like oh that's not
going to happen have you been tracking
prices yes so so
i just said 12.92 for a six-pack of
avocados
semi-rhetorically so we went out to eat
and uh we went to a mexican restaurant
it's it was it was i think me and three
other people
and the bill was 100 bucks that's low i
mean i keep kosher so
i think that's slow but yes but but it's
like
a year ago it was like 60 bucks really
yeah i mean if we got a couple tacos it
would be like you know 10 bucks a person
we're looking at 40 bucks with drinks i
get takeout for my family of seven and i
have small children it's
nowhere under 150. wow you can't do it
we don't what area are you in if you
don't mind me silver spring maryland
it's here yeah yeah i mean also i keep
kosher so you have to like put a 30 tax
on life but i mean
do i
keep track of tax prices
the local chinese place the just the
dinner special went up over 35
it is now 19 to get just a dinner of
chinese food yeah wasn't it like 10
bucks a year ago or something like that
no i mean his prices went up i mean and
i'm not blaming him obvious i'm not
blaming you but like it's just it's
crazy yeah and it's only the beginning
it's only going to get worse this is the
inflation is the largest tax on the
people of the world and and
your wealth is literally being
evaporated because of the financial
policies of the u.s federal reserve and
the biden administration
i'll tell you what was really scary for
me we went we have we have our truck for
transporting materials and stuff and for
removing the trailers and the mobile
studio we had to get an oil change
we were told we can't do it we don't
have any oil what we went to an oil
change place and they told us they
didn't have it and they couldn't help us
and then i was like what and they're
like you're gonna have a special truck
it's a dodge ram it's diesel yeah but
they were just like we don't have the
oil you have to get you i'm sorry we
don't have it what does everyone else do
i mean like it's not like we live in
like manhattan we had to drive and we
were in the middle of nowhere we're out
here you know west virginia we had to
drive to a couple stores to find
the right uh uh oil we went to i think
we went to like an auto zone or
something and then we were like i forgot
i forgot the oil that we need i'm sure
everybody knows exactly what we need and
they had i think like four
uh
gallons or whatever and we needed i
think three two or three maybe maybe two
or something and so i was like just get
it all because they told us that there
was a shortage and they couldn't help us
they could they didn't have any and i'm
like wow that was that's never happened
to me in my life yeah in my life every
vehicle i've ever had my friends
vehicles they pull in they're like yep i
mean that's what i did with baby i i
nursed my be like he's never had formula
and when all of this stuff started i
bought a canister because i was like if
i get hit by a truck yeah i want i want
that one hand one thing people are
mentioning the super chat's uh def
shortages what is df so i think it
wasn't i think 10 years ago there was a
uh
the us passed a bill requiring all new
diesel maybe it's longer than this but
all new diesel vehicles need to have
diesel exhaust fluid which is basically
urea and water
and you so when you when we're filling
up the ram with gas there's actually two
holes a small one and a big one if you
go to a truck stop you can pull out the
def and stick it in and it smells like
piss because that's what it is
yeah but we import it
and so there's already shortages if the
truck doesn't have it it it it gives you
a warning and says speed will be reduced
to five miles an hour
that is dystopian is that a part of
their global warming yes
what def does is it bonds with the fuel
so that instead of making a pollutant or
whatever it makes water or something or
something like that it's like a nitrogen
something i think a lot of people egr
deleted their uh diesel trucks and they
don't have to do that
and i think there's some local state
jurisdictions that made that illegal but
it's it's kind of hard to but sometimes
people are going to start hacking their
vehicles oh yeah they're going to try
and find ways to reduce the cost in
whatever whatever way they can
yeah i mean i looked into i mean at the
end of the day i don't know how much you
could hack
seven dollars a gallon
right bio diesel make your diesel from
corn i don't know
people are gonna be driving that but
that's not that's not that's not
effective i'm surprised that the
government is not having more of a
dialogue about getting people to become
self-sustainable it still seems like
they're like hey wait for us to fix
things for you wait for us wait for us
right i mean they're saying you know
drive a tesla but you have to spend
fifty five thousand dollars minimum wage
if
because those are the the regular prices
that you could pre-order i know people
that are making money just off
pre-ordering tesla's because of the
value of how much they've been rapidly
increasing so they order one that's that
they're going to get in a year or two
years and then of course their value of
it skyrockets up and the value of the
battery goes up so they sell it as soon
as they buy it and they make a profit
off them and you when you pre-order you
don't even put down the money right you
put down like 100 i think now they want
200
uh whatever it may be 500 i mean i don't
know i've put down a deposit on a ford
transit this week so yeah an expert on
affordable what do you think what do you
think the white house is talking about
in these trying times press a guess
matthew mcconaughey makes powerful
appeal for gun control at white house
because this is something i care i care
so deeply about seeing celebrities come
out and talk about gun control when gas
is five bucks a gallon it's just oh it's
so smart good job it's brilliant yeah
and the poverty that they're creating
will lead to more crime will lead to
more people
why do they want to take the guns
exactly
so it's actually not really matthew
mcconaughey's problem so this is the
next story in an emotional appearance
the white house briefing uh room on
tuesday matthew mcconaughey matthew
mcconaughey made an emotional appeal for
greater gun control measures at once
evoking anguish and hope how he asked
can we make the loss of these lives
matter oh so he's outright saying he's
exploiting the tragedy for political
it's nice of yahoo to write uh this
press release as a news story yeah did
you say in an emotional appearance he
made an emotional plea
that's so yeah he's really considerate
rather than logic he brought the shoes
of one of the children there and he also
brought a painting of one of the
children there that lost their lives
this is also on the heels of one of the
teachers coming out and also now
during that incident talking about
another
important aspect of the story that again
contradicts the police official version
there's so much to this that that again
is filled with just emotion so you don't
rationally think about exactly what
happened here but it wasn't even a real
emotion he was looking at a script like
for half the the talk it wasn't like a i
mean you call it a speaker but it was
basically a cold reading of a script he
was so obnoxious and you were saying
before we started he wasn't even no he's
like a tv and film actor trying to do
theater and he's shuffling his feet
looking all nervous looking down like at
least get off book if you're gonna try
and lie to me make me think that you
believe what you're saying dude he said
we this is a quote we need to raise the
minimum age to purchase an ar-15 rifle
two and then he looks at his notes
21. like he doesn't even know what he's
talking about it's like the most basic
talking point i didn't even know what it
was
and meanwhile he's able to afford
private security he's able to afford
guys walking around with guns that are
going to protect him and he's making the
argument that of course no no you can't
have that no you're not responsible
enough flippantly said red flag laws
which would get like people with medical
marijuana licenses to get their doors
kicked in if they don't want to get
their gun over you know like come on man
what is he what is he thinking well i'm
pretty sure if you have medical
marijuana you can't get a gun you can't
not in maryland no no no no no not
anywhere yeah what about people that
have a gun that get a medical mirror
unless you're hunter biden unless you're
hunter by then you can do whatever you
want that's interesting that's fair if
so um if you guys know in the chat if
you have weapons already and then get a
miracle medical miracle medical
marijuana card i wonder what happens but
you cannot
buy a gun
so
if you if you go to a gun store it asks
you do are you an illicit user of any of
any and it says in bold letters note
marijuana is illegal at the federal
level and you must that's a problem in
itself they call it a narcotic at the
federal level it's conservative isn't it
schedule one schedule one narcotic like
it's like a nerd i just i'm like no i'm
really boring i don't do any of these
things please give me my guess
the history of that marijuana being
illegal is insane to begin with harry j
anslinger colluding with uh what's the
paper the paper industry randolph first
person william randolph first and they
basically went and they did this this
propaganda piece called reefer madness
and scared a bunch of people and then
they made it illegally you know anything
that basically was the foundation of our
country yep i i don't care for smoking
weed or anything like that but it sounds
like gun control to me yeah because
you've got a lot of young people who
don't know or don't care you've got
people who walk down the boardwalk in
california and they're told just spend
five bucks and get a weed card and
they're all disqualifying themselves
from having guns that's insane that's
one way to do it right yeah as they're
registered with the state and there's
there's been many instances especially
in colorado california where you hear
people denied the ability to defend
themselves because of going through this
process then you hear about the fbi not
actually being able to get through all
of their backlog of background checks
so i don't know well that's why we have
the 72 hour release and this is what
they still can't get through it well
right but this doesn't matter because
after 72 hours it's gone right and you
get here you get you get your gun joe
biden's trying to get rid of that and
that would effectively ban all guns all
of them period how
so if right now the rule is
you have to get a background check when
you buy a gun from an ffl right
uh for the average person you get
researched and within 5 10 minutes
you're cleared right however sometimes
you get delayed if the fbi does not
complete the background check within 72
hours you get your gun right if that 72
hour release is removed as per joe
biden's you know demand then the fbi
will say we'll get to it when we get to
it and then you never get the gun i mean
that actually happened i so i got my
first gun in highland park new jersey
which is like one of the most liberal
townships yeah no it's bad it's bad they
banned fracking like this is how they
spend their time and the hoops that i
had to jump the illegal hoops i had to
jump through to get my my gun license
were
completely illegal there's nothing i
could do about it they just kept on
calling me into the back office are you
sure
are you sure and then they were sort of
misogynist and infantilizing because i
had my kids with me and they're like i
just
are you concerned about your safety are
you concerned about the safety of your
children like i am concerned about your
ability to do your job in a timely way
and i would like the ability to defend
myself and my children because i don't
trust you sir you you police officer you
because you're not very good at yourself
i had the cops in new jersey telling me
to get a gun really yeah
some guy tried breaking in and the cop
was like if you've heard me i answered
the door with a shotgun and i was like i
don't have one he's like well he might
want to go and i was like okay
and they they all lied to me as to how
to do it well the thing that kills me
about this story is that the lesson of
this texas shooting is that we should
never have guns
after we watched what the cops did
standing out there for an hour what was
an hour
i'd i would rather have a gun to protect
myself and my children because the mom
who jumped the fence
she's the hero of the story and the
border patrol agent
borrowed the shotgun of his of his
barber
he is the hero of the story and i am not
super interested in entrusting my
children and my safety in the hands of
those people
i'm a back to blue person and i'm
definitely not but what happened
what happened in ivaldi is not rare it's
not uncommon this happens a lot this
happened throughout other school
shootings
parkland especially just one of them but
there's other events my friend joe
lazito dealt with this entire situation
as police officers were watching as he
was stopping a serial killer getting
stabbed in the head police officers are
have argued in many states and even on
the federal level they have no duty to
protect
absolutely and it's important for people
to understand so for them to use this
emotional kind of event in order to push
for gun control so people have to depend
on the police is absolutely insane
disingenuous and just absolutely stupid
and the only way they could do it is is
is if they have enough emotions and this
is why we're seeing such hyperbolic
range and this is why we're not seeing
the mom who had to jump the fence yeah
and that mom right now was being uh
threatened according to her she came out
saying that she's threatened by police
yeah i'm not surprised for for for
speaking out against them yeah i mean
this is what happened in parkland that
it disappeared so fast once it became
clear what had happened and they don't
want to talk about it and so it kind of
it the story became the the hog it was
his name andrew david hogg thank you the
story became david hogg and all these
things instead of the dad who kind of
stood up and was like i'm sorry can we
have a conversation about what happened
with the police department yeah the
teacher came out today the the teacher
that was in the classroom where he lost
all of his students came out and said he
had to pretend that he was dead for over
an hour he heard police officers and
then he said that they retreated they
went away and when he went away the
shooter started again hurting small
children and this again contradicts the
official story of what the police
officers were telling us that day but
they were that they were outside no they
left they retreated they ran away and
then the the shooting actually continued
and escalated and more people lost their
lives when they didn't need to and the
cops are right there it's disgusting
it's absolutely insane yeah no so i
don't know if this panned out this was
like a sort of i heard it originally
when all this stuff happened they were
telling kids to yell out that's one
story as well and that happened one of
the teachers uh this this teacher that
came out today did an interview with abc
news and he said specifically
how
you know we heard the police officers
outside we thought they were coming in
we thought they were rescuing and then
they just left and then one student said
hey help me i'm here and then the
monster came in there and then and then
obviously you guys do you guys see what
david hogg tweeted about not allowing
not having immigrants come to the united
states like the weirdest gun control
talking point he was like someone should
tell
immigrants not to come to the united
states we should issue warnings in their
state their country should issue
warnings and i was just like
that's just like
i don't know what his point was trying
to be but he went like anti-immigrant
to argue for guns like
i don't know it was just where he goes
was he trying to art yeah right i just
think that we should just let him talk
all the time i i'm i'm of the mind every
time he opens his mouth we should all
just listen and just learn
agreed i think so too if we ignore him
he's gonna and belittle him he's gonna
get more powerful so it really is
someone that we should communicate with
well no she's saying that the more he
talks the more he discredits himself
i understand but i also think that he's
the kind of person that if you make fun
of him and act like he's not a big deal
will become way more politically
powerful than you intend well look when
half of
the political space in this country is
people who are willfully ignorant
and then accuse everyone else of being
willfully ignorant i don't know how you
solve for that problem anyway i mean you
see that in no more clear context than
with guns they do not understand the
very basic mechanics yeah i'm thinking
about policing because i'm kind of with
you luke that you can't really rely on
cops to save you but like i think okay
that we start from the beginning again
then you you have your homeschooling
your kids in your house you have guns to
protect it but that's not scalable
because you can't be on guard all day
that's why we develop specialization as
a species we have people that
specialize in defense of the community
well no no no armed societies are polite
societies and if you look at some
examples specifically when when a
criminal knows that someone could defend
themselves they're not going to treat
them
like like a victim they're going to know
that there's going to be consequences if
they aggress against somebody else i
understand that but coordinated attacks
you can't no one dad is gonna be able to
stop i i am probably the only person on
my block who has guns and i'm very okay
with everyone knowing it because at the
end of the day it's not my house getting
robbed
yeah luke i think your power cable might
be on your microphone or something yeah
i'm trying to troubleshoot it but i also
got to switch cameras but but on that
note bethany there's this uh viral video
james o'keefe recently posted it where
they went door to door
and asked people if they were in favor
of gun control and when they said yes he
was like
we have the sign saying proud gun free
home would you put that in your front
they're like no no like why not cause
then people would rob us and he's like
sounds like you're saying you need a gun
to defend your home the funny thing is
these people who won't do it no they
don't need guns because everyone else
has them yeah and so i agree people
should be armed i think or at least have
the right to arm themselves and let
people know we're armed um but on top of
that you're still going to need a
community police force at some level
because
you can't expect parents to only to
always be on guard if you're teaching
your kid you're not on guard so at some
point you're going to have to rely on
your community
to protect you at some point in in some
instances
maybe it's just gotten too big like
having a small police force i saw this
chaos in philadelphia the other night
maybe two days ago or something and
there were like four cops i think were
there at this huge crowd of like 100
kids 100 people out in the street
shooting each other yeah well the crazy
aspect is you know the same kind of
democratic party establishment the same
kind of individuals that that are
telling you you can't have a gun you
shouldn't have a gun are the same
individuals that are usually financed
and sponsored by individuals like george
soros that literally are financing da's
and public prosecutors that let
criminals leave and get out of jail
after committing very horrible violent
crimes there was a crazy incident in los
angeles recently with a mother that that
was run over by by a crazy criminal the
criminal got five to seven months at a
camp uh in response to him running over
a mother and her child again there's
been so many instances of of just
horrible violent people being led out
into the streets and these are the same
people
doing that telling you you can't defend
yourself you can't have you know we need
more laws to go after law-abiding
citizens that of course won't be
following uh the the context and pretext
that they want them to let's talk about
a new law oh yeah this guy we got a
story from the post millennial
california lawmaker who relaxed
punishments for sex offenders proposes
mandatory drag queen 101 class for k-12
students yes so
when the left demands something and the
gop ignores it they get it when the left
demands something and the gop pushes
back they recoil and then demand
something twice as bad
so we have all of these stories you may
have seen the story where
there's a big neon sign saying it's not
gonna lick itself and children are
dancing and with with sexualized adult
performers at a nightclub that was doing
a family event which is not for families
but uh they're claiming it is and in
response to this this guy is like why
don't we make it mandatory in schools
because this is what they want to do
in response to a texas state
representative announcing he will file
legislation to ban drag shows from
having children in their audience
california state senator scott weiner is
it is it weiner or weiner i'm going to
go with the wiener
proposed offering drag queen curriculum
in schools responding to a tweet from
rep brian slatten of texas he said this
guy just gave me a bill idea offering
drag queen 101 as part of the k through
12 curriculum attending drag queen story
time will satisfy the requirement so i
don't think he's completely serious you
know i think he's just meant like poking
the bear
but the fact that they've gone beyond
defending it and are now publicly being
like let's do more let's do more let
them keep saying it i know that's how i
feel too i mean this the end of the day
we're sort of it's not a mystery why
there's going to be an absolute tsunami
and it's not just this stuff it's not
just the over-sexualization of children
it's also the fact that parents over the
last two years were watching their kids
on zoom and things right oh this wasn't
very impressive this wasn't very good
and
i now know i mean if you look at the
test scores out of where i live
montgomery county maryland used to be
like
65 to 75 percent of kids were sort of
adequately prepared to do algebra in
middle in middle school the latest
testing is
fifteen percent and so parents aren't
just seeing this but they're seeing this
instead of math
and we need to monetize gaming gamify
algebra for kids where they get tokens
math is racist
in homeschooling i mean this is this is
the beauty of you know opening the
market
there's a viral video going around where
someone said that he went into this
event
and there was a little boy
and then
someone like the bartender asked him if
he was gay he said no and his mom went
yes he is he is gay he says no i'm not
you got really angry munch houston it's
my cousin
or or i don't know if it's i don't know
if that's munchausen that's ver like a
mother who's like i'm a special mom i
have a special she wants to fit in she
wants to be a part of whatever this is
i i i don't know how many of these
parents there actually exist i mean i
would like to know if this guy actually
has children because at the end of the
day so heroes of liberty the books that
i do
we were just reviewed by current affairs
and the reviewer had no children he's
like the socialist with cats and he has
no children and he's like this is what
parents should be teaching their
children this is what they should not be
but none of them actually have kids they
don't have anything in the game they do
they have your kids right i mean that's
the thing they want to capture our kids
in k-12 kids i so again in montgomery
county where i live
the
there was just sort of an announcement
put out on like the mommy list serves
that normally at our
local
zoned elementary school they've hit 100
kids by now in kindergarten enrollment
this at this point they had 100 kids
right now they have 55 kids signed up
for kindergarten and they're starting to
panic because by june 30th they're going
to start having to fire kindergarten
teachers because they're not going to
have enough
kids registered and they keep on passing
the buck they they got federal money
over covid to sort of
inflate their budget
because people were pulling their kids
out but that federal money is now gone
and they're they're screwed i want to
pull up this tweet from libs of tick
tock who writes the mayor of apex north
carolina announced that the drag queen
part of the pride event has been
cancelled after feedback was received
from citizens but it's more interesting
than that
the letter
from the mayor says
it continues to be my goal to ensure
that all voices in our community are
present are represented i have received
a variety of feedback regarding the drag
queen story hour at the upcoming apex
pride festival
given that this part of the event was
not originally presented when the event
was proposed i met with representatives
from the organization hosting the event
the apex festival commission and
presented the feedback i've received
from citizens today i was notified that
the apex festival commission has taken
the feedback into careful consideration
and has decided to remove the drag queen
story hour from the event they tried
sneaking it in
they didn't announce it they get their
access and permitting whatever they need
and then they add child sexual grooming
they don't even have to sneak it in this
is something that they love doing so i'm
kind of surprised that this was a
response because this is their entire
reason
is like sexualizing children so i don't
know why they had to sneak it in when
it's like normally just you know part of
pride week now
i think they
they know that if parents the average
parent sees this there's going to be a
major backlash i mean but this is not
out of school right like this is just a
public event that people can attend
well so here's an interesting moral
question
the what the there's a martin bailey
kind of thing going on where
in the bailey you have them outright
just
sexualizing kids it's not going to lick
itself and then when you call it out
they retreat and say it's just a costume
party it's oh that's all it is a pageant
show and then and it's like dude
they're sticking dollar bills in thongs
there's photos there's queen lectacia a
nine-year-old boy touching a nude adult
man in a photo shoot these are grooming
kids sexually that is over abuse yeah
yeah no i i i don't get it yeah and
of course they were also talking about
drug abuse and and there's different
layers of this i think this all kind of
coincides with a larger depopulation
agenda if we go down the rabbit hole but
but to me there's a lot of different
aspects of this that really do need to
be understood here and parents being
responsible for their children is one of
them i feel like a lot of them feel that
they could just give a screen give a
computer put them on netflix and their
child is going to be okay and they're
not you need to be a part of your
child's life and you used to be able to
outsource you used to be able to put
your kids in front of disney and and
bring them to the school library now i
mean especially in the month of june if
you go to your local library and you
look at the children's section it is
wall to wall may i just say that i am
absolutely in love with the fact that
they are turning parents into a voting
block i wish them the best of this
because this transcends everything this
transcends class race it transcends
whether you're gay or straight if you
have kids and you care about your kids
you're going to push back on this so
hard yep you're going to flip their boat
it's going to be great well we saw it
with glenn yonkin and they i mean i it
was funny i met this mom at a at a dance
my kid does a dance class and you know
very blue maryland and she walked up to
me and she sort of gave me a little bit
of her backstory and we were texting
later to you know get our kids together
and i was like oh you're one of those
blue red pilled moms from glut for glenn
young and she's like you bet i am
because i saw what they were doing to my
kids on zoom and i and they did not care
i mean it's not just that
that they didn't do it well it's that
they just did not care and so
what really frustrated me about this
call for everyone to enroll their
kindergartner in school
or the kindergarteners teachers will
lose their jobs when did the
kindergarten teachers express any
concern over children over the last
years i know that the the unions were
sort of the larger villains but i didn't
see that many teachers coming out and
saying we need to be in person and i
need to teach reading without masks on
myself for the children we did not see
that in mass and the psychological
negative impacts of the mask wearing of
specifically the distance learning is
going to have long-term consequences for
children that are not going to be able
to be socially uh you know available to
turn an entire generation into and i
don't say this in a in a bad way
into autistic yeah
they are not going to be able to form
these social bonds my my kid does
occupational therapy and most of the
occupational therapists patients are on
the autism spectrum and they've told us
like this is bad or have good human
interactions with you know the fellow
fellow children and fellow friends and
another aspect of this to really kind of
ascertain is that they're not going to
be able to have healthy relationships
whether with friends or with partners or
lovers and then you have the aspect of
pornography and how readily available it
is and how it literally rewires
children's brains and then you and then
you teach people not to have you know
you're essentially leading people down
the pathway where they're going to be
alone and miserable for the rest of
their life and i think this is all done
on purpose because then you have the
perfect consumer when you could you
could you could control someone you
could enslave someone when they're an
individual but when they're a family
when they're a group or in their unit
it's harder to control and subjugate a
population if you want to explain to
people who don't understand the damage
masks do it's actually quite simple
set the volume on a tv
just low enough to where it's kind of
hard to hear yeah and then
have have something playing the tv and
then ask this person what they said and
they'll tell you then block their view
of the person's mouth and play it again
and they'll say i couldn't hear it yeah
but why the volume's the exact same and
then learn how to read that way yeah i
mean what one of the most underreported
sort of stories of all the school stuff
is the violence in schools and people
are like well we wouldn't see this
coming when you dehumanize children put
them in literal glass boxes don't let
them go near anyone and tell them that
they are vectors of disease for two
years
there's gonna be some anger and then
over sexualize them and confuse them
with all these other things screen where
they're
ready access to the pornography exactly
and i was michael malus who said that
schools
are
maybe the place uh the one place where
our children experience violence or
something like that yeah what do you say
on par with prisons i think yeah
yeah yeah the same people who build the
prisons build the schools so what do you
expect i mean especially when you look
at the larger
people call an education education
system it's it's again an institution
that indoctrinates children for the
political benefit of the people
controlling that institution and this is
why david rockefeller was instrumental
in creating the modern day education
system trying to create factory workers
that were going to be good workers for
him and no one else treat everyone
exactly the same and everyone sort of
goes to the machine are you familiar
with john taylor gatto yes
he does incredible work and if you don't
know who that is you should definitely
see john taylor so he was an ed he was a
teacher actually he won teacher of the
year in new york city and during his
speech he sort of stood up and said this
entire machine is broken we treat
children as cogs in a machine and we
it's unnatural to teach anything when
you tell them okay read this poem and
then a bell dings and then they have to
move on it treats children as if they
are
rats basically absolutely yeah and the
homeschool philosophy that we follow
because i homeschool all my kids not all
of them obviously i have a baby but um
it's called charlotte mason and it just
basically yeah and it talks about sort
of
her entire philosophy is
the respecting the personhood of
children and treating every child
as an individual and it's
this is what the education system should
be and you know there are charlotte
mason schools that i mean this is this
is why people are are flocking away from
public schools because they treat
children
homeschooling is on the rise which i
think is is absolutely incredible
absolutely awesome pods are also
starting to exist entire networks are
starting to exist where people in a
community are coming together and saying
hey i'm a physicist hey i'm a
mathematician hey i know history on the
way here i was talking to an art teacher
she homeschools her kids and i said can
you teach an art class for all of the
other jewish explorers in our community
i was literally on the phone with her on
the way here there's huge networks
popping up and a lot of people aren't
talking about this new hampshire just
passed a lot of new legislation allowing
people to
homeschool even more freely and even
have more access to taxpayer funds
if they do home school and
they have entire communities of
individuals especially a part of the
free state project where you have an
expert in one particular field that
teaches an entire group of children on
the very specific issues that he's an
expert on my freight my friend jay noon
does this with welding he has little
kids welding and and building stuff and
constructing stuff he calls it uh i
think he calls it man camp uh he might
get cancelled for that
but but jay noon does great work and he
literally teaches
young women
young young boys how to build stuff out
of their hands uh out of their hands and
it's incredible stuff what they're able
to do when they're taken out of this
confined space where they're told just
to regurgitate something right and
they're told hey you have free reign to
create something and the things they
come up with is absolutely incredible
these kids have so much potential they
have so much creative energy they have
so much incredibleness within them and
the school system the indoctrination
system intentionally suppresses that to
make them good slaves people think when
you say indoctrination system that it's
you know you're sort of feeding all this
drag queen stuff which obviously is
happening but i think that the larger
point of indoctrination isn't and the
damage isn't
that messaging the progressive messaging
which i obviously think is really
damaging it's treating children like
they are cogs and like rats
rinse and repeat say this and
learning remember this think about how
we read books in in school they you have
to write a book report and then you have
to illustrate it and then you have to
and i hated the book by the end of it i
never wanted to see it again and then
when i read it as an adult i'm like oh
grapes of wrath is actually really
pretty good it's a pretty good read and
so i'm reading i'm rereading all of this
classic literature as an adult and i'm
like you
murdered this piece of beautiful
literature and i mean this is schools
all of us yeah i mean the only books
that uh millennials read have read is
harry potter those are actually good i
defend them sure sure sure i like harry
potter for sure but it's the only thing
they've read
for pleasure i would say i mean this is
this is the problem with um with also
putting kids in a pen for eight hours a
day at the end of the day they're just
fried and then you put them in front of
a screen whatever but they they have no
energy and no inertia to just read for
pleasure
i think we have to expand pods like so
they're really hard to put together let
me tell you as someone who spent the
last three years trying it's
it takes more
coordination because then you have to
rely on other people and i don't know if
you remember group projects when you
were a kid
never rely on someone else to do it
because no one does it as well as you do
so i don't know if they have these where
you are but in colorado when we were
homeschooling we had these co-ops where
you could go and learn latin and yeah
yeah they're incredible but they're
super hard to form
and then so this is like just my
personality i hate rules and
i don't like people telling me what to
do
and a lot of the pod a lot of the co-ops
near us were crazy with covid and so i
just didn't want to partake and a lot of
them i mean
we sort of fit into a sort of weird
ideological box because we're jewish and
because you know whatever and so it's
hard to sort of find
like-minded people but we're i mean
we're trying to form that where i live
but um but it's hard it's hard to
coordinate what about doing it online
coordinating online so we do so my kids
do an online like hebrew class or
whatever and the teacher is wonderful
but i don't want my kids in front of a
screen all day yeah not all day i would
think there are some things you could
learn online so they do so my kids do
it like it's called gesher and like it's
it's base so the problem with the the
jewish model and like my
experience and my perception is that so
in the jewish community people 95
percent of people send their kids to
jewish day schools like orthodox i'm not
talking about reform so if you actually
like care about your faith um
you will send your kids to these schools
but they're like twenty thirty forty
thousand dollars a pop
and so if it's a kind of birth control
because people are like oh we can only
really afford to have two or three kids
yeah so people have two or three kids
and so
it forms you know
sort of it becomes birth control
basically and so
what some people do but very few people
is that they pull their kids out and i'm
talking like two percent of people home
school right now and the woman who runs
this program that my kids do she runs
all of the jewish classes online on zoom
um but it's hard i mean it's hard for i
mean the the jewish community does not
homeschool on mass and i do not
understand it it makes no sense because
we have the financial constraints of not
just the the tuition but also you have
to live within walking distance of your
synagogue and so there's a jew tax on on
your house because
it's gonna be it's it's the home value
and it's also the property taxes and so
it's really expensive to be jewish which
is like you know there's a reason why
there's all the stereotypes about us
being cheap because we're really tight
things are expensive
kosher food is also super expensive and
so
i don't get why there's not more jewish
home schoolers but
i think
i can easily attribute much of my
success to the fact that i was
homeschooled before kindergarten so
you know when i was growing up when i'm
a little kid my mom's homeschooling me
from
our earliest memories until we even
started kindergarten
and then i learned later on none of my
friends had any schooling that they were
you know three and four years old doing
very little if anything you know getting
a little bit of instruction from their
parents but mostly nothing i was
actually you know every day we have
grammar books we have math books and
vocabulary and all that stuff
and so i i started researching schools
because i despised them completely i did
uh k through eighth grade and then i did
a couple months of high school and then
just stopped completely with all school
yeah so you're there for an idiot was
that they're they're for an idiot
because you said oh oh of course
absolutely and you didn't turn into
anything yeah so so the issue is you
know i remember when the conversation
around college was happening
and
people were surprised to learn you don't
need a high school diploma to go to
college but all of my friends were
convinced they they had to have one and
i was like once you turn 18 you can just
go to community college get an
associates and then transfer you don't
even have to turn 18. i have a friend
when she realized that she she was
completely sold on homeschooling her her
i think sophomore age in high school
he's already going to community college
by the time he graduates high school at
18 he'll have an associate's yeah
exactly great and so it's a complete
waste of time yeah well i remember when
i when when i was told don't worry high
school is going to be different and then
what was it identical in every way and i
was like
right right i was like how many times
are we going to learn the exact same
things over you're teaching us nothing
so i was like i'm done yeah i went to
new york city public school that was
extremely um brooklyn
i don't want to kind of release the name
of it i went to two high schools and um
when you're there you have teachers that
are absolutely horrible that that
absolutely ruin learning ruin literature
ruin your ability to even you know have
basic you know functions and there's
also you know teachers that do care that
i had teachers going up um i i could i
could i know four of them off the top of
my head that used to say okay this is
what they want you to learn this is
what's going to be on the test now here
let me tell you how the cia brings and
brings the crack into the poor
neighborhoods here let me tell you about
uh iran here let me tell you about jfk
here let me tell you about you know gulf
of tonkin and and there was four
teachers throughout my entire uh life in
new york city public school that were
absolutely incredible caring loving
individuals that did a good job that
actually made you understand what the
world was really like but that was rare
yes and the vast majority of them i just
hated school because it was just like an
indoctrination i love homeschooling i'm
super raw raw but the problem i think of
conservatives is that we think that
homeschooling is like a scalable
solution for a lot of people it's not so
here's the problem you had four teachers
who were caring and whatever
when you get into the parenting world
and you realize how few parents care
about their own children that i think is
one of the most earth-shattering i've
been saying this and people didn't like
it i said
you've got how many parents that would
prefer to have a job
knowing it meant their children are
being groomed than to risk their their
comfort and their access to just their
comfort i like i'm just going to be
really mean for a second it's not just
their comfort it's they just don't want
to spend time with their own children
right and this is something that i i
truly do not understand as a parent
because and jordan peterson talks about
this who your children are are basically
under the age of 10 a reflection on you
so if your child is a real
then that means that you're not a great
person either and i always say to my
daughter
because we we have like social issues if
the parent is liberal they sometimes
don't want their child playing with my
child and this has been a reoccurring
issue in our family unfortunately and my
daughter was really disappointed for so
i'm just i'm just gonna be honest with
you honey that person is a jerk and
their child therefore
is not someone you're going to want to
play with socially because plus i don't
why would you fall far why would you
want your kids hanging out with them i
mean that's exactly it the child is a
jerk and it all i mean this is people
keep on talking about sort of this your
child's socialization whatever with
homeschooling and i'm like it's a
feature not a bug because i don't have
to have my children play with any of
those jerks kids i know who they're
playing with it's not about a jerk
necessarily but it's also about social
contagions yes 100 i was the bad kid in
my class all growing up i was the one
that told all my friends about sex and
drugs because i did not grow up in a
great house oh no i did not grow up in a
great house and i was the one that told
all my friends about do you know what
sex is do you actually do you want to
talk about like you were that person oh
i was awful my gosh i'm protecting my
children from myself at seven that's
great yeah let's let's jump to this next
story
this is uh
this is fun cnn's new ceo plans to prune
partisan personalities and programming i
hope they fire brian celtic poor brian
upon taking over from for jeff zucker
chris licht has vowed to make changes
among them as a reduction of partisan
programming and on-air personalities
if he gets his way
on-air talent could be ousted if they
can't adjust to a less partisan tone and
strategy so here's here's going to
happen brian stelter is going to do a
segment where he goes this is exactly
right we shouldn't be partisan it's
funny how whatever you do his voice very
well what whatever whatever the company
wants to do he's just like of course
that's the right answer but here's the
problem for brian
one day i don't know when it will be but
one day they will actually make hiring
and firing decisions based on ratings
that is the day that brian sees
the end of the road so i mean obviously
i support this i think this is great but
let's just make it a meritocracy
but if they did that then tucker would
be on cnn
yep i mean it's crazy how the cable
cable news used to be tucker was on
msnbc
really when he used to have he has to
have a bow tie yes he did he used to
argue
msnbc nbc used to be kind of like
corporate or like you know it was like a
crossfire thing right no no i think i
think msnbc was considered to be like
center right or something oh wow yeah
it's only it's only recently that msnbc
turned into a far hard left weird
liberal democrat thing i think that's a
lie really no yeah yeah yeah sounds like
fake news to me they got bought by
comcast at some point
interesting
didn't they have jessie ventura on and
yeah
in 2008 and they canceled his contract
because he criticized the war when they
told him to stop um
yeah his middle tucker carlson was on
msnbc yeah he's like this one's the
situation you know when comcast broke
out yeah
and rachel maddow and jay severin were
featured guests
interesting isn't it crazy how this
stuff used to be yeah
i don't think tucker carlson
if anything he's become more populist
yes so he used to be very staunch
conservative he was a conservative guy
on crossfire so him being on msnbc msnbc
was not this hard left weirdo thing it
is now i think
but it's
it looks like it's been moving less
since 2008 that's when they cancelled
tucker
that's just what i'm seeing i did not
know this i don't know that's nbc i had
no idea i've only gotten them as i
thought it wasn't only me yeah no i i
followed the news closely and i was like
so that's 2009 is when comcast
uh well actually they announced that
they were buying nbc universal and then
it was 2013 when they actually bought
universal now you see blackrock state
street and vanguard own 20 or whatever
18 of comcast
uh so it's just this media consolidation
see what the banks with wells fargo now
owns whatever else other banks in
comcast
is just dictating the narrative yeah the
more you consolidate anything like that
i think the worse it's going to be i
think we are seeing all this
corporatization because at the end of
the day like three companies own
everything bet you that more people
watch
your
show
more people listen to it that's for sure
and i'm not talking about words they're
hearing i'm not saying they're hearing
more people hearing i'm saying they're
actually listening yeah no i mean i this
i mean this is the brian stalter thing
you can respond to this show it's a
completely different ballgame but this i
mean
it's
that's why it's popular though because
people feel like
there is they're invested in it and they
are part of this yeah whereas brian
stelter when you watch it you just feel
like you're
you're on the receiving end of a really
bad lecture who would sign up for that
yeah that media that whole uh that genre
is is gone it doesn't doesn't make sense
i mean some people i guess are used to
it so they're still comfortable with
being talked at but so we i just pulled
up ad week's ratings are up to date but
they don't let you read them unless you
log in and you can't log in because the
system doesn't work for whatever reason
so but i pulled up this is from uh
national media spots msn so fox news 1.5
million in uh
what what what is there what is their
number is this prime time
i don't know i think it's i think it's
prime time viewership peak so fox news
gets 1.5 million their average viewer
though is i think what 62. yeah yeah
okay
they do get a lot on the advertisers
because oh my gosh yeah pocket catheters
but i think tucker gets around 400 to
500 000 key demo viewers
which is uh basically what we get
it's about the same number but we're not
getting any of the other demographic
right like that we don't get any target
demographics so tucker gets you know
three to five million people watching
his show
ten percent of them are key demo he has
massive influence i wish that you hadn't
said that now i'm just gonna sit here
terrified the rest of this [ __ ] i
intentionally shield myself from this
kind of information what how big the
show yeah i just i like to think of just
to sit next to us
but it's also different too because we
get that
over the life of the show so like
i think
off season politics we're getting like
350 to 450
uh on youtube and then we get like 100
on the podcast
then we do the clips which get another
six or seven hundred right right so
it's different from how cable tv works
yeah yeah but it's it's definitely
changing and changing for the better so
i'm what i'm wondering is
i'm wondering you know from an internal
business perspective and from a cultural
perspective what's the upward limit of a
show like this
can we ever be as big as sucker
crosstalk it can be infinite i don't
think so neural net it can be infinite
everyone on earth can know everyone on
earth it can really be like that well i
i don't think i don't think that's
possible right now and there's no reason
to predict in the foreseeable future
that would be the case yeah i would give
it 70 years or something when people
watch cable tv there's like seven
channels they would choose from on cable
news and that means automated all of the
conservative people are going to watch
tucker when tucker's on when it comes to
the internet you could watch this you
can watch viva you could watch jimmy
watch crowder like it's it's made me
realize how small the world really is
when you when you break through you make
a youtube video and then 18 million
people know who you are the next day and
then
with the neural net i mean i don't want
to i don't want to break the
conversation and start talking about
tech that doesn't exist yet but it seems
like we're headed towards an environment
where we're more interoperable as
i think fame is going away and i
predicted this 10 years ago i was at um
what is it called nab in amsterdam
national association of broadcasters and
i was talking to these guys and i said
fame as we know it is going away and
they're like no it isn't that's not true
that'll never happen
and i said
what i explained to them was the
internet is decentralizing how we
consume media
new clicks new groups new subcultures
are emerging and they're exponentially
emerging so where it used to be that
there were 10 channels there were three
channels to choose from then there was
five then there was ten
you would have one guy
on that nightly show with you know the
with johnny carson or whatever how many
guests would they have two or three
and so everyone in the country has to
choose between these five channels
so you've got 100 million people all
watching tv
20 million watching this one show and
that one guy that's on it is seen by all
of those people i mean this is now it's
it's
there's there's 50 shows to choose from
yeah and i think that this is part of a
larger sort of
our our culture is sort of we're not as
connected anymore because it used to be
that everyone used to watch the same
shows and and you listen to the same
music or whatever and now you were
talking about some stranger things
before the show i was like i've never
seen that show and i have no intention
and i i can do that i can operate in a
world where i've never seen that show
because how often does stranger things
come up in my everyday life not that
often but if this were 50 years ago and
i hadn't seen johnny carson last night i
can't talk at the dinner table i have
nothing to say and so i i think that
it's really sort of
not just bifurcated but just like
atomizing all of us into our little
bubbles is it a good thing or is it a
bad thing i think it's a bad thing well
it depends because it's also the
decentralization of power and
information that's fair
it's a good thing when it's meritocratic
what's happening now is
the establishment and the lefty cults
are manipulating the platforms to prop
up bad ideas when bad ideas are propped
up against metocratic ideas then there's
conflict yeah it's painful i don't know
if you call it good or bad but it's pain
spiritually it's painful to not know
what other people are thinking or caring
about well also powerful people
manipulate the perception with bots and
spam accounts and fake accounts to make
ideas look more popular than they
actually are if they have an agenda in
pushing it and that's why i think the
elon musk spam kind of debate is a lot
more important than we even understand
right now but
another aspect to to kind of look at
here is that you know the corporate
media a lot of their viewership is dying
off
they're they're they're slowly you know
passing away of old age and and i think
you know tim you make a good statement i
think it's the same kind of statement
that andy warhol made when he said in
the future everyone will be famous for
15 minutes and i think with you know the
digitalization of everything i think
that's where we're going i think that's
where we're at almost um
as a certainty in in the near future
yeah i mean you think about sort of
america's sweetheart like jennifer
aniston and sandra bullock and all the
like do we have that today exactly
that's what i'm that's what i'm saying
like does that exist and to me i i'm
very emotionally invested in rachel
green aka jennifer aniston's procreation
but now she's 55 and it's not going to
happen
those magazine covers are now over um
and i'm not emotionally invested in
anyone the same way i'm invested in
jennifer garner well i think one thing
that we see
there used to be beloved celebrities
yeah now we have celebrities who are
loved and hated
so well smith yeah well so it's one of
the last ones because back in the day
people were like do we really want to
run
non-stop of the nastiest coverage on
someone that people kind of like a lot
it's risky right if someone is hated and
infamous well then you run the the hits
and the tabloid garbage but if it's a
celebrity you're like people are
interested in celebrity life and
lifestyles are the rich and famous now
though you can hit them both you can
make a magazine called celebrity love
and you can make a magazine called
celebrity gossip where one says will
smith is the best and the other says
will smith is garbage run them both get
both audiences and make money off the
hatred and the positivity yeah meghan
markle is like the the key demo on that
oh
thank you it was so hard to watch fringe
you can she's in a lot by a person what
they think about meghan markle yeah well
why is that she sucks that he's a good
person yeah
this is prince what is it prince harry's
wife yeah i just can't stand
did you guys see the video of was that
meghan markle talking to the little kid
and the kid was like giving her the yeah
oh that was no that was prince louis i
i'm i'm a royal i'm a real royal style
tell me about it i'm a royal fan i've
been in imbibing like
you know intravenously all about so you
know a lot about lizards
what's that what's your favorite lizard
so i have no this is what i was watching
i'm a gila monster guy myself
i got this new ai story gender i got a
there's an ai program i just subscribed
to it's called open ai it's really
amazing you can tell it to do anything
you can say draft me a product proposal
or like give me a catch phrase
and uh i said tell me a story about
donald trump defeating the lizard people
with his good friend alex jones
and it wrote this really amazing story a
couple of them i i ran where one was
like trump was at a rally when in the
stands he sees a couple lizard people
and masks shouting and he points points
him out and everyone starts booing and
then he goes into the stands with alex
jones like or he it was it was just an
absolutely ridiculous story one was like
a lizard guy breaks into trump's house
and he throws alex jones's book at him
and hits in the face knocking him out
making me think of scorpion from mortal
kombat remember that he would take his
mask off and he had like a lizard mouth
we got the masks okay now what's next
that wasn't scorpion scorpion was a
skull okay so we could because we hire
all of our writers
um you know what i'm thinking luke you
mentioned corporate i you were talking
about the corporations earlier i think
that when a corporation gets big enough
when it becomes a mega corp it should no
longer be called a corporation and it
should have new laws and rules about
what it can and can't do own land no you
can't own land if you're
uh all sorts of stuff like this like oh
own software private software code no
you can't use that stuff if you're a
mega conglomerate you should be broken
up first of all so we got to figure out
ways to make the system so that it
cannot grow to a place where we're going
to ever have to break it interesting
proposal but a lot of the rules and
regulations made the corporations as
powerful as they are right now because
they made smaller businesses and
competitors at a disadvantage to the
people who are friends with the
politicians so
do you think more rules and laws will
save that that's a question that a lot
of people are asking themselves i'm a
little bit more skeptical of that i'm
very uh libertarian usually for the most
part but there's one thing i think the
government should be focused on is
breaking up monopolies and and making
sure people don't become economical but
they're at the end of the day they're
they're the ones who are going to be
able to get around all the laws like
there's no law that you could write that
would make jeff bezos do anything right
well you can make him free the software
code of his systems you can't make a
copy
i don't agree
they all that happens is it's like
there's 50 million cracks in the surface
and you are plugging one but i can't
give up this is like the founding father
sitting around like there's nothing you
can do to stop king george nothing
i would never not live in that same
thing i mean it's kind of like we're
having that same conversation all over
again with corporations that's jeff
bezos you're inverted it would be like
the king saying there's nothing we can
do to but like if the founding fathers
gave up before they started i can't give
up on this there are definitely ways we
can use law and order the government
would be the crown in this analogy
i think it's bezos i think bezos and the
not jeff particularly jeff but i'm
saying megacorps are the modern-day
monarchy the problem is we're not
fighting
fair like at the end of the day we're
all
if we're fighting against jeff bezos
it's in the court of law and
they have the power in that circumstance
for fighting like hand-to-hand combat
like they they did in the revolutionary
war maybe we have a chance public
opinion is where it's all at what makes
you think that the government's going to
work in the benefit of the people they
never have there have been studies
proving that it's a scam the special
interest the people with the money
essentially call the shots push the laws
they get them passed because they want
them passed yeah and and they're the
ones that are served here the the super
rich we have socialism for the super
rich and everyone else gets screwed
that's essentially the system that we're
living under right now that was the
lesson of covid amazon made how much
money yeah amazon walmart costco they
did a study and found that public
opinion has no effect on what bills get
passed only the opinion of the top one
percent yeah lobbyists and people
literally when they would look at they
tracked public sentiment on certain
issues and then bills being passed no
correlation right yeah democracy is a
scam the founding fathers didn't rely on
their government to save them from king
george they just made a new government
i mean so that's basically what has to
happen of course
here we are yeah revolution starts here
so the the issue is i don't think it's
that hopeless i think
the fact that trump got elected shows
that you can yeah get somebody in and i
think what needs to happen now is uh
robbie starbuck he won his court battle
he's back on the ballot
we need to go out in the primaries and
vote for
people who actually want to help this
country so here's the problem as someone
who lives somewhere and i tried des you
have to find people willing to do it and
you have to find people willing to stand
up to i i spoke to so many people i
again live in montgomery county maryland
i spoke to so many people who were
incensed by what happened in in
montgomery county they closed the
schools the longest they we were
subjected to all the coveted rules the
longest out of anywhere else in maryland
and people are terrified of standing up
and just saying in an unpop what they
think might be an unpopular thing or
submitting themselves to
the the mob of you know when you run for
office people think that they own your
soul and they try to destroy you i you
have to convince people and so like the
people like robbie starbuck who are
willing to stand up and say i am i'm
ready to fight are so few and far
between because people lack really
really basic courage
yeah i'm thinking about how do you stand
up against a government but the thing is
when i say we need a new government it's
not that we need to trash the u.s
constitution it's great it's the
corporations i'm concerned with and we
can use our government and the structure
of the constitution to defend against
that
the best way to make a government
obsolete is to not need it and not to
depend on it and that's why personal
responsibility is is my choice of a
solution
letting people be healthy
happy healthy and productive and and
just overall living a good life is
something that of course the state does
not want you to have and i think if we
did we wouldn't need a lot of the
government
that we have in our life what do you do
when
the dude who's like two miles upstream
from you and your friends little
farmhouses starts taking a dump in the
water
what do you do when monsanto poises
poisons the entire food supply when they
create gmo everywhere what do you do
when they have control of entire crops
that literally spread throughout the
entire world that there's no stopping
right so that's the situation that we're
dealing with but now we have monsanto
protected by the state that's right
so monsanto is protected by the state if
we didn't have a state we agree on that
when you then get to the circumstance
where somebody is like upstream from you
and it's a legitimate question i'm not
getting you
how do you like what's the effective way
to respond to someone who's not willing
to cooperate with you and they're like
polluting your water
very i know i have no question i know
the big corporations aren't doing it
already
like how do we solve this my
counterpoint is yes it's already
happening um we'll deal with that
problem as it comes but that problem is
is less of a problem with that one
individual compared to a multinational
corporation that that literally has a
monopoly and could do whatever they want
and are destroying the soils and when we
look at the larger impacts of it is it
an individual stopping this and stopping
this one person okay fine i would argue
that there would be less harm that would
be there would be less pain there would
be less suffering if there was more
decentralization because of
centralization we have monsanto we have
glyphosate we have the rise of horrible
cancers we have the rise of factory
farming we have the destruction of our
soils that's getting rid of the
nutrients and minerals in there that's
creating very severe health problems for
the rest of the country so i would argue
that with this system we have more pain
and suffering than if we didn't have
this kind of system and if we had more
decentralized what happens when you get
a monopolistic power like monsanto
regardless people argue from this
perspective that of course the market
would respond people would know that
they would be voting for and supporting
something with their dollar and they
wouldn't be doing so but that that's an
argument that's an argument to be made
here
that some people are making the other
perspective of it is of course that
they're so powerful that they can't be
stopped and they'll be willing to do
what they can tell you
in california
you have these small farming communities
with no water because of the drought
yeah and the farmers couldn't get
surface water because it was voted to go
to the cities so they would drill
thousands of feet into the earth for
groundwater
the small farming you know migrant
houses only went down 30 feet for their
well so their wells ran dry very very
quickly this was devastating and what
happens is the people in the big cities
are like
why should i care
to vote in favor of those people right
it doesn't matter if it's your dollar or
your vote your ballot the same thing
would happen that's why i'm like i don't
know what the solution is be it the
state protecting or the private company
just hiring private military to protect
themselves i mean i think a lot of this
sort of goes back to what we were
talking about like the atomization
people just don't care about you know
their fellow man anymore when we have
nothing in common with people and we
don't know who our neighbors are you
don't care about if someone downstream
two houses down and you're taking a dump
in their water because you don't know
who they are and you don't care anything
about them this i mean this is the sort
of breakdown of community that tim
carney talks about a lot ben sasse talks
about a lot when we have no connection
to our larger community and you don't
even know i mean do you know who your
neighbor is do you know his name
i live in an rv
i travel
and when i do it i do i met an excellent
awesome my last stop was in sarasota as
soon as i pulled into the rv there's a
culture there yeah i had three people
back you know helped me get my rv into
my position afterwards two people came
to me and they're like hey look you want
to are you hungry we got food here we're
doing a barbecue there i got two offers
for dinner and i was and and they're
like our you know and you know we talk
about politics and get into different
perspectives and uh you know people
you know especially in the rv community
are a lot more open and a lot better
than a lot of other people in closed
communities in big cities yeah because
it's very sort of everyone has to help
each other i drive around here people
wave they're super cool people are ready
to communicate it's just a matter of
doing it yeah we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already smash that
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
if you really do want to help us out and
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up at 11 p.m monday through
thursday we do this we'll have enough
tonight for you let's read some of these
super chats
super chats
all right outside sound says just saw
the biggest beanie i've ever seen in a
billboard on the corner of halsted in
chicago avenue and in chicago nice work
guys you are the media captains now
that's right big beanie you are the
media captains i sent uh the the the
agency sent me the photos of the chicago
ads they're great i didn't realize how
big they are one of them's like i think
it's like
50 feet tall or something can we keep
them afterwards yes
that's awesome they they are they
physical media their physical vinyl that
they print you should go get them yeah
absolutely they mail them to us i guess
i gotta yeah i just got to pay like the
shipping and they send them 100 it's not
that expensive either
so um
the other thing is
i just found out we are getting free
times square ad slots
so we're going to be rolling up some
more ads nice yeah i mean it says
something interesting about the traffic
in times square right now
yeah so here's the funny story we bought
two billboards and right now they're
just big tim cast ads right next to each
other and when i was in new york i
noticed one of them was off it was a it
was a digital billboard screen it was
off and so when our ad ran there was
just a single ad and so we're getting
we're getting additional space to add on
to it so i was like cool cool we're
gonna run some we're gonna do some cool
stuff we've got some plans for uh the
next few months in the marketing
strategies we're gonna be doing and
we're gonna be doing culture jamming as
marketing
so we're just gonna
you know
mischief
yeah just massage the toes of the
culture mischief
you know just like we're gonna put up
ads and we're gonna do things that are
gonna make people go what
you gotta stimulate that lymphatic flow
it kind of reminds me of fahrenheit 451
when you like awaken people to the
when you kind of open their eyes to
what's going on what's the website for
the mines festival it is
festival.mines.com let me double check
that
festival.mines.com we're going to be
there on the 25th right yeah 20th of
june this is going to be huge it's going
to like james uh did they announce tulsi
gabbard yeah okay because you guys
almost said it tells us
west is going to be there
dude yeah luke's not going to be there i
think we'll see
that'll be the selling point i got
invited but i don't know if i'm going to
go you guys want luke say it in the
super chats give a super chat for luke
if you want luke to come smash the like
button because we can get him there and
then if we get 20 000 likes luke's
promise to go i i never said that but
you guys are pulling my leg here i'm
promising for luke that he'll that he's
he's he helped to break his promise that
i made up all right let's read we got
here dan says hey tim typically i listen
via podcast and rarely get a chance to
catch your live show keep on keeping on
you guys lydia is the best also check
out stellaris if you think civ games are
awesome i love it dolores stellar's
degree it's real time but it is really
really good space game all right jeb
reid says every single republican who
signs on any gun control bill will have
their political career ended they will
be joining the private sector this fall
agreed
oh man yeah absolutely
dilly dilly says luke is back nature is
healing
spring springtime springtime you were
here in what like february yep
all right
recre morrison says golden rule of
democrats accuse opponents of what
you're doing biden lost in 2024 and
won't leave they'll do what they accused
of trump in 2020. they did that in 2016.
in 2016 they were like oh russia and
they did an investigation
they cried and they won
all right robocat says luke you're so
cute marry me
okay
whoa you just accepted your purpose
that's that's not a verbal contract now
right i'm ready i'm i'm in trouble
flambeau says you know what would fix
all of our problems graphene i know no
it's not a silver bullet but this fiend
structure this is this uh hexagonal
lattice structure they have it with
boring boron two borophene it really is
graphene when we start producing this
stuff in mass and can start building
stuff out of it we're not gonna need
steel we're not gonna need copper as
much it's going to be transformative and
let's get trump talking about this
all right blue
goyer
says we have hens we've been glassing
our eggs can preserve fresh eggs up to a
year with filtered water a 5 gallon
bucket and hydrated lime i think you can
do technically two years can't you they
uh
they're not as good after you've you've
had them stored for a long time but
their food
yeah you ever see glassed eggs no we
have a jar downstairs
yeah they're like preserved preserved
eggs that's really cool yeah they last
forever well they last for like a year
samuel pyle
says if there is not a red wave this
election i do not see it ending
peacefully i completely disagree it's a
midterm
the presidential election year is going
to be crazier because you have congress
and you have the presidency right now
it's a midterm so we'll see
logan culver says we need a revolution
any any any highlighted evol oh like
love luke do you think you would be
disappointed if dave smith took the helm
um i don't trust any man or any person
um everyone should have a check on their
power no matter who it is especially if
they're part of a revolution
revolutions usually turn um into you
know worse situations historically and i
think the the commentary was talking
about more of an evolution and that was
the kind of slogan by ron paul uh it was
a revolution but it highlighted the
evolution part which i think is much
more important to concentrate on
especially when it comes to personal
development
cool
goldilocks production says my state
nebraska never locked down either and
while we had a mask mandate loads of
people flat out ignored it and irl was
so was
and irl 2 was scarcely enforced only in
omaha and lincoln was it really enforced
interesting
what do we got david toronto says
florida was a bit strict for a while
miss stopped all the all the crap a
little before florida and we have
constitutional carry
i don't think florida has constitutional
not yet yeah yeah
yeah democratic places like miami
definitely um weren't largely
representative of the entire state matt
lucas says 13 gallon tank times six
dollars equals seventy eight dollars
slash seventeen gallon tank time six
dollars equals a hundred and two slash
fifteen dollars per hour net pay nine
hundred ninety six dollars and sixty
five cents in ca something has to give
that's right yeah when the cost of
driving to work exceeds the amount of
money you make people will just stop
someone someone said that she she was a
stay-at-home mom in this like large
families group and she said i have to go
back to work to pay for my husband's gas
so that he can go to work
wow what are you saying man i don't
think we do we don't know this interest
to the federal reserve
why don't they just use private jets i
don't get it i don't understand
did you guys see the adp jobs report the
small businesses were completely gutted
yeah it's like medium to large
businesses we're all fine but small
businesses were all wiped out
i mean i i have several i mean i i'm
friends with a lot of the kosher
businesses in my area and they they're
very frank about the i mean like jesus
talk about money and they they talk
about like their their chicken costs and
their their labor costs and everything
and they're just like
i have to raise my price by 35 because i
have no alternative and then people
don't want to buy their stuff anymore
because we can't feed our family for
under a hundred bucks anymore so i mean
we don't get as chinese as much
ardwick says biden isn't lying the
economy is great have you seen the
revenue numbers now that everything is
costing triple or quadruple what they
did 16 months ago it's like that dan
aykroyd skit from jimmy carter when he
was like don't you want to own a 5 000
suit smoke a 50 cigar i want a 5 000 car
all that stuff or whatever i remember
that one yeah
it's great isn't it
cj stedman says if you think having an
electric car is a solution wait until
the brown outs hit this summer that's
the other thing that i'm telling you we
if every car was electric the grid could
not handle it yeah that's just
yo it's crazy man
in
incompetent hands says my hat says make
america florida i wear it every day but
can't remember where i got it some loser
i guess i wonder where he wound up i
puked nightly but only from all of the
potatoes and whiskey shim cast for life
i would be careful with that potatoes
and whiskey diet and are you talking
about maybe this hat that i also have
here coincidentally make america florida
one of my favorite shirts yup
steve jones says fox news is pushing red
flag laws like cnn watch the a block of
the five tulsi gutfeld perino and the
rest were all aboard as a conservative i
am sick of fox
gabbard tulsi tulsi is in favor of gun
control good i want to talk to her about
it yeah she's wrong
but that's okay she's also wrong about
nuclear power gutfeld is wrong perino
per rhino but uh i assume jesse waters
was not in favor of red flag laws red
flag laws will mean
that armed police can just come to your
house and violate your fourth amendment
rights that's it that's ridiculous
it's going to be abused just like every
other power that the government has yep
let's see so and and b says so in db or
every method between ian free the code
crossland and luke hates gates ratkowski
i'm surprised you got you guys haven't
had linux put on all the office
computers yet that would be good we have
limits
yeah i'm going to start viewing away
from calling it free the code free
software because it's confusing makes it
sound like you can't sell it you can't
it's called copy left software it's
different than copyright because this
copyrights are free and left and open
morgan h says ian please get excited
about thorium we need thorium reactors
to solve our power issues yeah i've
heard great stuff about thorium for
about 18 years have you guys been
following it same exact thing it's just
super hot metal that doesn't produce the
nuclear waste byproduct but i don't know
enough about it to go well it's like
it's a liquid
system isn't it i don't know i don't
know thorium salt reactors yeah where
you melt the salt and then you get
endless amounts of heat from the molten
salt it stays hot overnight you can keep
boiling water when the sun goes down
here we go mike gibson says there is a
popular mechanics article from october
1st 2009 by daniel tam claiborne about
burning salt water with 13.6 megahertz
frequency microwaves
13.6 megahertz here we go dude you've
got to check out john kansas it's
k-a-n-s-u-s
saltwater burns on youtube there's video
of it from like
2008 and it sets off a 1 600 degree
flame it's basically and you see a gap
between the salt water and where the
fire starts just like on the sun below
the corona you see that gap where
there's no flame so i think the sun
might be getting a frequency that's
making it light up like a flame ball so
if we can get the salt water which is
done in a test tube in the lab but take
it into low orbit where it coagulates
into a sphere and then you run the
current through it it's going to light
up like a star
yeah this is crazy josh oh my gosh says
tim a friend of mine works at a baby
formula plant and he said the problem
isn't the production it's the shipping
he says the warehouse is full of baby
formula i blame the lockdowns and diesel
costs
wow
yeah a lot of drivers don't want to
drive because it costs more to drive
than than it is what they're getting
paid to drive the trucks yeah i mean
that's everything that's not just baby
formula that's everything under the sun
that's why we have supply chain
shortages of
everything
steve brown says tim if you need a
luthier give me a shout out is it
lootier or luthier how do you pronounce
that i don't know guitar maker we do
we should do uh some custom we talked
about this a while ago custom tim cass
guitars to hang up
uh email spin the ufo gmail.com and then
we will we will figure out custom
guitars
um i would like only my all of my wood
to be rare and imported from exotic
places
or just you know i don't know maple or
whatever you make a guitar out of
something nice
something nice yeah i'm thinking the
guitar body could be a t looking thing
with the eye as the neck and then the m
on the body
from the endurance on the bottom of the
ocean they just found the endurance
that get the guitar made out of the wood
of the endurance wow that'd be crazy i
don't know if it would sound good though
no it does sound terrible
it's all about
mike roman says i drive 425 miles a day
delivering pharmacy drugs to nursing
homes like everyone else i can't afford
an electric car i also don't believe in
them for many reasons some of which you
mentioned already
pedroza says master automotive tech here
your cars are now digitally controlled
your car is constantly monitored by a
gps and internal can systems your
steering speed and braking can be
controlled already you will own nothing
and you will be happy
yeah so i was mentioning mentioning this
the other day basically every car is
self-driving yeah and they can be
repo'ed very easily without your consent
so we so i have a tesla
and it's got self-driving we're all
excited you're on the road and you go
boop boop on the thing and then all of a
sudden you're like whoa it's driving
itself that's like keep your hands on
the wheel and then it it cruise controls
and the wheel turns and it's driving and
we're like wow and then i got a honda
accord same thing no different what yeah
honda cord is a button you press it and
it just drives the car for you my honda
odyssey from 2018 does not have that i
can tell you really yeah i can tell you
right now
2019 civic has it yeah no i mean i bet
you my my 2023 ford transit will not
have that either
so i'm i'm thinking what in 10 years no
one will own cars you ever see those
birds scooters or lime scooters or
whatever all over the cities
you never see those scooters lined up oh
the annoying things that people trip
over all the time yeah absolutely that's
what cars are going to be like that
every car that's absolutely nice that's
what they've been aiming for and uber
but it's not already working i mean this
is like this is my internal bugaboo like
the war against families you cannot do
that with kids you have car seats you
have crap i have like a snack box in my
car i have a diaper box in my car i i'm
not mobile i wish i were i wish i could
just jump on a scooter but well this is
why it's going to be more convenient to
be in a pod and honestly
traveling in your virtual car convenient
not to have children this is this is the
end this is the end goal here is to stop
us the breeders what people don't
realize about the self-driving car
revolution this is what's going to be
funny
they talk about how uber is going to be
all self-driving no drivers the cars are
going to be owned by uber you're going
to call and the car itself will pull up
and you'll get in we see it in modern
sci-fi films that they've been making in
the past several years the cars are just
good to go
what will happen if you walk into the
middle of the street
right as a car a self-driving car is
speeding it's going to slam its brakes
on and stop right
so people knowing they can't get hit
will just jaywalk everywhere and all the
cars will constantly be getting jammed
up and stopped new york will be chaos
you won't be able to drive in new york
because if people know there's not that
well but sure but if they switch to
self-driving cars you still need to
deliver things right
so if the trucks are doing deliveries
and they're all self-driving people are
going to be like i can't get hit and so
no one will ever stop for the crosswalks
yeah but people don't actually put two
and two together it's kind of like
with everything going on with diesel
shortages and whatever people don't put
two and two together that when gas
prices go up their their grocery prices
grow up and so new yorkers are going to
love jaywalking and they're not going to
put two and two together at the point
they're not getting that's my point yeah
my point is no one will stop for a
self-driving vehicle there's no one to
get mad right but that but they're not
going to understand that
new york becoming more and more
unlivable is a product of their own
doing right that's my point the city is
really not getting it the cities will
collapse
because people are going to be like i
don't care yes and they're just going to
walk in the street and the cars are
going to be stuck and unable to move yes
then there's going to be a self-driving
car you're going to call it but no one
will stop walking because they won't
care about a robot they're like there's
no one in the car to get mad at me right
no one will complain and they're never
gonna stop in the car which is not
making an argument for facial
recognition citizen you have been issued
a ticket
not when there's 300 people every 10
seconds crossing the street like you see
in new york yeah unless you have a
social credit score and facial
recognition systems like they do in
china where they just take a photo of
you and automatically deduct your money
out of your bank account i think the
future that's where we're headed and
ideal maybe ideal thing is tunnels in
cities i know elon's been working with a
boring company one of his companies to
bore tunnels but like in could you
imagine new york city how cool would be
if you walked out of your house and it
was just grass
you know how long it's taken them to
build the east eastside subway system
they're never going to actually do it
they spent like 30 million dollars on
one staircase in times square 30 million
i i went to high school in new york city
i'm i'm a graduate of new york city
public schools also and uh
it's not a great scene no all right we
got brownie ninja he says i'm from i'm
home from winnie city pony con oh cool i
went to danny's and villa rosa as you
suggested they're just as good as you
said they were happy seeing your shout
out with 430 000 views also tried lou
malnati's giordano's portillos and home
run in a plus all of them
lou malnati's is good giordano's is good
portillos we ordered a whole bunch we
got a bunch of hot dogs here those are
fantastic home running is absolutely
delicious but those are the tourist
things in chicago villa rosa and danny's
pizza were the local pizza places i used
to eat when i was growing up and i was
actually surprised villarrosa is still
around because it's i was like a little
this is like 30 years now they've been
in business longer than that probably
but i'm like 30 years ago we'd ordered
pizza and it'd be from villa rosa so if
you are in chicago that was the place we
would always get our pizza from yeah
danny's danny's was further away so
depending on where we were it might have
been danny's but it was typically
villarreal check out the art of pizza on
north ashland too uh apparently they're
still around man that's some
mega deep dish oh really good really big
yeah you might as well just get uh
spaghetti it's like eating a shot of
pizza
and then it expands slowly over time so
if you eat two really fast you get
really lenny's pizza in brooklyn that's
that's all i have to say
all right
based for life radio says my son will be
participating in a homestead homeschool
co-op for kindergarten learning how to
care for chickens livestock gardening
composting aquaponics shout out based
for life radio for independent
anti-establishment grunge punk rock
here's what you got to do you got to
teach your kids how to how to take care
of the chickens do you guys know about
the placebo effect oh you're probably
familiar with it and there's a nocebo
effect which is also a big trip the
scientific method can't really account
for why the placebo effect seems to work
but in the medical industry they're not
allowed to tell a patient you're getting
healthier because they can get sued if
the patient dies i wonder if in the
education system they're not allowed to
tell a kid you're going to be you're
succeeding you're going to be great
you're going to solve the world's
problems because they think there's some
liability but kids need to hear that
they need to believe that they're great
to do great i feel like that's all kids
nowadays here
all they hear is they're great yeah yeah
i mean when they get your participation
and believing it like having it honestly
said is different than yeah but who says
anything honestly nowadays i do
all right here's an interesting one we
got trd i i can't read your name dude we
have five vehicles in my household
converted all of them to compressed
natural gas we fill them with a small
scuba style compressor from our
residential gas line for 75 cents per
gallon
cng is 120 octane no power loss 300 plus
miles of range how do we do that
that sounds amazing i want a natural gas
car i heard about that right super cheap
it's methane yeah we should uh is it
methane they use it in europe too um
because of the the you know how
expensive gas is there so um yeah i've
stopped i i in poland i saw a couple
people even use um like have those tanks
in the back of their trunk and and set
up their car to to run on both
so we got all these chickens
we're gonna have to eat these roosters
i'm not gonna complain yeah there's like
three of them screaming outside my
window every three we have like
15 when they all start chiming in that's
the that's there's three silky people
they wake you up
five o'clock i've started to get used to
them they were in the beginning four
o'clock seven o'clock so that's like me
with my kids yeah but then i ignore them
i treat it like traffic now and it
doesn't bother me because i grew up on a
busy street oh yeah well we're building
the boys dorm and we're expanding it for
damastan because right now roberto's
over there and then we have the triplets
we call them and they're nasty the
triplets are mean roosters
we thought roberto was going to go in
and tell his sons what to do but they
were not having it so way to separate
him it was not not nice but roberto you
know he's he's retired he's an old man
you know so we got to take care of him
to follow up what you were saying about
your kids are you kind of like let him
cry it out kind of mom i i will not get
out of bed before 6 30 unless there's
some real screw screeching going on
which like i had a kid who was sick all
weekend and today is what tuesday like
today still feels like friday because i
haven't slept
but i will go in there when there's like
a kid with 103 fever and sick but
all right rhian gauze says tim poole
says salt water is not a solution
chemists yelping everywhere that's funny
yeah that was a good one that was a good
one
1776 is life says as a farm kid living
in a small city i started growing my own
food and hunting fishing more my family
can rest easy for our food storage but
please make sure everyone knows how to
preserve food if you ever need to try
hunting hit me up in illinois we uh we
made jams last year we're gonna do it
again this year because we have mulberry
trees everywhere i picked way too many
strawberries at the strawberry farm on
thursday oh strawberries are great yeah
we have a wineberry season is about to
start
so the entirety of like appalachia's
just riddled with these wild chinese
raspberries
and we made we made raspberry i made
lemon wine berry jam i made wine
basically just like a parting gift when
i leave we don't have any for you no i'm
sorry and if we did have it i would not
give it away we have frozen wine berries
we made a mulberry jam and then i made a
mulberry wine berry mix them together
and then we also have we have
blackberries
we had
black raspberries growing
and we have tons of pawpaw
i was i didn't realize because paul paul
season they call it hillbilly banana
yeah it's in end of september october
and so
i'm looking at the trees and i see like
three and i read how they're like hard
to grow and they're hard to pollinate so
they're kind of rare and i'm like okay
well maybe we'll have a handful to try
out
when paw paw season came you couldn't
walk through the forest so they're
getting hit without getting hit in the
head by a papa they were everywhere you
would shake a tree and like 15 would
fall down and then we ended up having
like 50 or 60 of them brought them in
and nobody could eat them because
there's just too many but they're
delicious and they're just everywhere
it's fantastic yeah i should bring my
medium here yeah
you made a bread didn't you yeah i
didn't put enough sugar in it so it kind
of came out uh mealy did you like kind
of grainy i think it needed to be like
uh maybe boiled or cooked you need to
just do it like a regular banana bread
recipe but using popcorn yeah something
like that and then oh man you know
what's really great chive
grows before grass when the season
starts changing so we had crazy chives
everywhere it's so good we were putting
it in everything yeah yeah my daughter
walks around eating onion grass like
it's actual food it is it is food it's
delicious i mean she just she just eats
it she walks outside i'm like you know
the dog pee's over there right i don't
care
well it's all food right
all right let's grab a couple more super
chats
one mountain mama says look up c11 in
canada right now canadian content
creators will be moving to the us
uh i know a few who are trying to
what are they banning free speech again
or whatever
gorham says can you guys please address
the fact that tulsi gabbard is a world
economic forum young leaders member the
same as dan crenshaw they look good but
go closer anyone in the we in the world
economic forum is an emperor not a
leader
so here's what dan crenshaw said
he said he has nothing to do with that
list it's an editorial they put out on
people they like now that means a lot if
the world economic forum is saying these
are people we're looking at i'm kind of
like why
but it doesn't mean they're directly
involved so i'll ask tulsi you know we
do this event
we'll see yeah and dan you know feel
free to come on the show uh dan's not
coming on we've been we've been waiting
uh and i think it would be great to have
a conversation where we could go over
you know a lot of the misconceptions
that people have he agreed to come on
then he said yes then his guys said
they're scheduling conflict and then
outreach is canceled on us i know i just
flew for that oh that's right i flew you
out there i flew hero that's probably
why they canceled they're like oh they
brought luke back well can't do it we
could have a cordial discussion that i
think would be very productive for
everyone involved all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button unfortunately we
did not get to 20 000 likes so luke will
not be coming to this event in new york
as as uh as he wants to go to new york
city
i promised for a look that if we had 20
000 likes he'd come but what is it right
now close 11 11. oh that's not even
close it's not even close definitely not
something
so no luke but don't worry everyone will
puke you can uh uh subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com we have that
members show coming up for you about 11
p.m and you can follow at tim cast irl
everywhere follow us on instagram for
clips we put up every day you can follow
me at timcast everywhere bethany do you
want to shout anything out yeah so
heroesofliberty.com is the children's
books that we do on ronald reagan
john wayne we talked a lot about like
masculinity and stuff and this is sort
of our antidote because
teaching boys that it's not a bad thing
it's not not toxic um and you can follow
me on twitter bethany schonder so i was
looking at the chat during the show and
i just wanted to shout out the person
who called me a dollar store bill maher
that one
that one god
absolutely and julian assange if assange
and bill maher had a baby
i think so
anyway also people are asking me who's
on my t-shirt it is of course the late
john mcafee uh this is a t-shirt that i
have available on
thebestpoliticos.com i have another
different version only available for
members on
lukeuncensored.com as well as two videos
coming out today one of the original
report another with health
misconceptions if you want to see all of
that sign up on luke uncensored.com hope
to see you there for a very important
conversation thanks for having me in
addition to bending light with sound i
want to give you four words to remember
me by here for until tomorrow maybe uh
turbostratic twistronic flash graphene
remember those words turbostratic
twistronic flash graphene look up those
three things flash graphing turbostratic
graphing and twist traumatic graphing
you're going to be 3d printing some mega
structures certainly such an object was
dreamt up by you ian
oh yeah i believe there there are ai
working on it as we speak
this is really funny i told the ai write
me a story about ian developing a
cost-effective means of producing
graphene and it actually wrote how to do
it yeah oh yeah yeah they were talking
about chemical vapor deposition which is
crazy that's rudimentary at this stage
it's like a five-year-old technology now
we're using lasers to pound carbon and
turn it into like layers of it to make
these like you know um super conductive
materials i'll go deeper at another time
and before i go i wanted to read one
super chat i've never done this before i
thought it was kind of important some
aaron preston he says the def shortage
is due to the fertilizer shortage urea
is a component of both eat or drive you
will have to choose which is a very
interesting observation because we are
actually talking about that in slack
urea is a component of fertilizer comes
from bat cuano you guys may follow me on
twitter and mines.com at
you can also catch me tomorrow where i
co-host on pop culture crisis with brett
and mary it's always a lot of fun
there's nothing to worry about with gas
prices i mean if df is shortage like i
can eat you know we can all eat or drive
because i have electric motorcycles i
have several of them so yeah just just
buy an electric motorcycle or a tesla
what's the big deal thanks i have guns
so i also feel pretty confident yeah
yeah what is what is the joke the people
who don't have guns are are stocking up
for the people who do
yeah
all right everybody we'll see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out
you